Hello, everyone.
Am I on the screen?
Yes, you are.
You're on the far.
Why are you so...
Hello, everybody.
You know why?
I literally told you why!
Hello, everyone.
Okay, I will admit, that was it.
My bad.
Oh, sorry, I pushed...
I moved you off my screen too.
Oh, oops.
I forgot to also tweet.
Whoa, you're gone from my screen.
No.
Whoa.
Goodbye.
Hello.
I'm trying to do it.
Oh, whoa.
What is this square anyway?
Whoa, where does she go?
Oh my God.
Why is this square so big?
Okay.
I'm trying to like make her bigger on my screen.
Why is dad dancing on me?
He's dancing.
Don't worry.
She'll come back very soon.
She's alive.
Very much so.
I'm trying to fix this real quick all right he's dancing
he's dancing he's dancing there you go there you go now
you're appropriately sized on my screen
yeah let me get it all right that I was sorry that is a my
bad because I made or may not have taken a nap um because i
was like mint like message me and was like we are playing
middle gear solid right and i was like yeah in like an hour
and a half and then she was like okay good because my chat
for some reason is telling me that we might be playing
fortnite and i was like oh yeah i need to show you my skin
collection oh no i think i'm good i think i'm good
me uh but I definitely show you my skin collection later on
um anyway so right after oh it was very light don't worry I
turned her down I actually had her hello hello yeah you
should be fine now because I had you had a weird ass setting
earlier I don't know I don't know why was my discord setting
was really weird uh but it should be better now um anyway
where was I good am I good hello hello she should be good
now right guys is she fine now they're saying yeah she's
fine yeah no i actually had you like at 2.0 and i dragged
you all the way to minus 9.6 i don't know why you were at
that far uh what yeah yeah that was weird uh i think maybe i
had like collab where i had to turn everybody up or some
maybe yeah but if i sound dead to you it's because for those
who don't know i got sick over the weekend not even i think
like on tuesday or some yeah i got sick on tuesday i'm still
recovering um So that's why I took a nap, because I was
like, a little nap wouldn't hurt nobody.
Stop getting sick.
What do you mean?
You get sick more than me.
What the fuck are you talking about?
You're always getting sick, because you're always traveling.
You don't practice your social distancing.
You don't.
I'm literally, I have to be inside people.
It's not my fault that they, like, pass through me and
stuff.
Yeah, every person who pass through gives you the germs.
yeah um and then and yeah and then i slept i slept through
my alarm i almost slept through my alarm i woke up i set two
alarms um i stopped my first alarm and then i turned off my
second alarm because i was like i'll need that i'm awake now
yeah i was like i'll need that it should be fine and then
and then i took a quick power nap of five minutes and i woke
up and it was like 10 minutes before the stream and I was
like, oh, fuck.
It's not even one REM cycle.
And then I messaged Min and I was like, hey, I'm sorry.
I just like, I almost slept through my alarm.
And then Min was like, oh my God, I forgot.
I'm done fast.
Bye.
So she forgot too, guys, even though.
I did not forget.
I was watching Detective Conan.
You're watching.
Wait, are you like up to date?
Were you like catching up?
with detective conan no uh there's like netflix has some
conan episode like specials on there oh so you weren't up to
date with the conan oh no i'm not up to date with conan at
all yeah yeah i mean how how can you be i think like they
have more episodes than like dragon ball z or one piece most
likely i got i was current up to a thousand geez wait
actually how many wait who has more episodes one piece or
conan because you know how like one piece literally just
ended their first season first season
i'm pretty sure conan like has been going yeah going on
longer than one piece in general okay google says one piece
is at one thousand one hundred and fifty five which means
conan definitely has more because they're at like 200
something wait detective they're at like only 200 not even a
thousand two hundred yeah yeah yeah that's what i mean yeah
i was like only Only 200.
Those are been lumps long.
You've been on hiatus.
Oh, it's close.
Conan is at 1,188, apparently.
Wait, what was One Piece?
1,155.
Oh, Conan, you're slacking.
They took too many breaks.
Wait, that means I'm not far behind Conan.
I'm only in like 288-ish episodes or something.
Yeah, see, One Piece was on season one.
I think Conan has been on multiple seasons.
Oh, yeah, Conan.
okay but what's weird is like yeah i know this is like
google maybe google being weird but google says like one
piece is at season 21 and no i think that's like arcs though
because like in japan like they're what they consider a
season is like arcs you know like uh this arc is now like oh
they ended the arc so that's one season done oh i know bro
that's you gotta revoke your Kevin, you didn't know that?
Well, I know.
I always counted when a new opening song or new ending song
is used.
It's a new season.
Is that how it usually works?
That's how it usually works at video, right?
I don't know that.
I don't know.
I just, maybe they just, no, because like half seasons.
Because like in JJK.
That's so half season.
No, because in JJK and season one, they changed their anime
opening midseason.
So you can't use that because they...
Yeah, see, not anymore, Minto.
That's how it used to be.
I'm a boomer.
I'm a boomer anime fan.
They switch open 80 midseason.
Hagalit.
Nah.
Nah, that's, I see people in chat saying.
I've never denied that.
Don't think you're any better than me.
Boomer.
Yeah, but that makes me younger than you.
Oh, 10% off gamer subs.
Use code Boomer.
Thank you.
Thank you for promoting my code, boomer, code boomer.
Or you know, you could use code JokeyBread on Fortnite as
well.
And because of that, I'm booting up Fortnite.
We're gonna show you.
No, because of that, I'm doing a, I'm showing you guys my
skins.
Wait, no, you can't leave.
We don't start Metal Gear until I get to show off my skins.
I'm holding this stream hostage.
It's okay.
At least I can show the iBoo's my Fortnite skins.
No!
God damn it!
That's what I come into here.
Alright, iBoo's.
Oh my gosh.
I gotta show you my new Fortnite skins.
That's why we're here, guys.
It's so cool.
Fortnite is so cool now.
Okay, look.
How about this?
only take it'll only be like five minutes I don't care about
your fortnight no please it's so cool it's so cool come on
come on give me this give just give me this are you gonna
get the south park ones no already right already got it
yesterday on stream oh my god wait wait check it out check
this out do you have Darth Vader oh I got I got Master Chief
oh that's not wait wait wait no no no It's so sick.
I don't because like you haven't been on Fortnite for a
while.
So like you're not caught up with like the newest Fortnite
updates that they have.
You have a sponge ball.
There's like there's sidekicks out.
Look at my look at my cracks.
Look at my.
Oh my God.
So so what Fortnite added is that you can have shoes now
too.
You can buy shoes.
So I have like I have Air Jordans.
So you can make your character wear like Air Jordans.
separately oh my god this is the greed they describe in the
bible yeah this is insane i am the consumer i am the target
audience so i can make karmic wear oh and i was skippity
toilet as my backpack yeah i see that and then so and he can
ride on shenaron too oh my god so they added this new thing
called sidekicks so they basically like follow you around So
I have Spongebob.
Why does he look so dead?
Like, yeah, he gets angry if you shoot at him, too.
So, yeah, I have Spotter Pig, too.
I bought Spotter Pig.
Oh, my God, Spotter Pig.
What's a dog?
Oh, the dog is just a Fortnite guy.
It's just his name is Pugh's.
Oh, he's cute.
Oh, he's like a banana.
There's itchy, too, but I forgot to buy itchy.
So you can have itchy and scratch.
Well, you can be scratchy and have itchy follow you around.
is going no they know they absolutely know yes i do mr beast
okay i bought mr beast and then i could put mr beast on
crocs and then watch yeah and then look at this
how do you feel i'm totally normal
A bunch of dolls dancing, it's cute.
Oh, and then I have...
Oh, my God.
I remember this sign.
Wait, go back to your characters.
I don't care about Mr. V.
Yeah, okay.
All right.
Okay, where's the...
I do.
Yeah.
So this is my skin collection.
I have Master Chief.
I have all the South Park kids.
So...
I have Stan.
Wait, oh, my gosh.
Batman looks so awesome.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Batman Beyond is in here, too.
Yeah, yeah, and then he can...
It looks so good.
Oh, my God.
But they actually did the shading so well.
Yeah, yeah, it looks just like the show.
Yeah, that's why I had to log in.
I was like, big announcement, guys.
And then there's Snow Meeku.
Snow Meeku.
John Cena.
Marge Simpson.
I have Ninja.
Of course, you have Daft Bomb.
Oh, yeah, that is Ninja.
Yeah, that is Ninja.
I got the Xenobar for this.
Oh, yeah, I got M&M.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Slim shady.
I told you, you've missed out a lot.
There's...
I don't think I missed out on anything.
No, no, no.
Look at that.
Yeah, and then there's Daft Punk with the Crocs too.
Yeah.
Oh, with the Crocs.
Oh, there's Alan Wake.
There is Alan Wake.
You can technically, you can get Alan.
Yeah.
There is.
I have to get Alan Wake.
So you can technically, you can play Alan Wake.
He's a writer, you know.
Yeah, I know.
He's a writer.
He loves the lake, too.
It does look, doesn't that look like John Wick?
Please be honest with me.
He does.
Yeah, he does.
It's the hair.
See, everybody, I'm not crazy.
I'm pretty.
It is.
If he had a black suit on, it'd be more like John Wick.
Yeah.
Like, Alan Wake, too.
Alan Wake looks just like John Wick.
Yeah, he really.
Oh, I can't wait for you to play Alan Wake, too, for just
the fucking concert performance.
What?
Oh, yeah.
No, no.
It's not a spoiler.
Spoiler, it's infamous.
It's infamous.
Literally, like, the Game Awards fucking was, like, had, it
got nominated in the Game Awards, and it feels like right
after.
I think I remember that.
Yeah, no, you remember it.
I know you remember because you did a watch a lot on the
Game Awards, and you must have been like, what the fuck is
going on?
Yeah, I was like, what is happening?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, where's your Metal Gear skins?
So, I don't even remember when they debuted Metal Gear Solid
skins.
but um so i have skins that you don't wow cringe okay the
skin collector but like you don't even have uh look you know
i pick and choose look at that time when metalgear solid
came out i never really played any metalgear game so i had
no interest in um collecting oh but you had interest in mr
beast ninja okay mr beast please include me mr beast please
include me in your next one million dollar challenge video
all the other creators.
Okay, what about Ninja?
Ninja.
Um, I did, technically, I did a collab with Ninja, so here
I, so, you know, gotta support the homie, you know?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
The Joker, the Batman who laughs, and then there's, oh, I'm
Mr. Me Seeks, too.
I know.
Yeah, I saw Mr. Me Seeks.
Look at me.
Oh, and then there's Frieza.
though with his crocs.
They're so creepy looking.
Why are they so realistic looking at the horse?
I think they're like, I'm pretty sure they like 3D scan the
shoes themselves.
Because they don't look like they were modeled.
They were modeled themselves because all the shoes looked
like they were fucking 3D scan.
Wait, what does Xenomorph look with the crocs?
Oh yeah, it looks great.
What does it look like?
Wait, what does it look like?
Oh my god, Queen!
Yeah, look, okay, wait, let me see.
She's so cute.
Oh yeah, give me, give me a dance, give me a dance.
I'll give you, I'll give you this.
Oh my god.
She's like even smiling.
Look, he's enjoying.
Oh my god.
God, look at him.
He's having a great time.
My xenomorph's a weave.
I also have, wait, what a, I'm going to, I'm going to go.
Wait, do you have the Mikubian?
Oh, no, I didn't buy that at that time.
So sadly, I do not have...
Oh, here's...
Come on!
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, this is my favorite.
Yeah, this one is the classic.
This is...
I also bought this.
I hope you get a DMCA.
Oh, 100%, I will.
I mean, the first playthrough already got...
strike because of snake eaters.
So I was just like, it's fine.
Oh yeah, it does.
It does.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's like a bunch of bugs back.
Oh, okay.
Anyway, so that is my collection.
What do you think?
That's alright.
What do you mean it's all right?
All right.
Oh my God, they're gonna go.
Oh cute.
Okay, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I need it.
Why is it so tall?
Oh my God, I'm watching this happen in real time.
Oh my God, it's in the shop.
Guys, remember to use my creator code, Doki Bird.
Remember to use that?
This is disgusting display.
No, you'll understand.
No, you'll understand when you see it.
I've seen clips of the repo people dancing and you'll
understand.
It's so worth it.
All right, let me buy my V-books.
Purchasing now.
Why are they so tall?
They have to be tall.
They have to be tall to do the dances.
To do the silly dances.
So gross.
Okay, anyway.
Oh my god, he's wearing the crocs too.
Oh my god, with the crocs.
He's wearing the crocs too.
And he has to wear socks with the crocs.
And he's...
The fact that he's wearing socks with the crocs.
That's great.
Look at...
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Ew, ew, ew.
Look at this.
Oh my god.
Ew.
No!
H-O-T-T-O-T-O You can take me hard to go Wait, that one's
fine, I like Yeah, look at them, look at them You hate it
You hate it, you hate it It's so good I've been waiting for
this to get back into the shop There's like a little
schedule thing Where it tells you when certain items will be
back in the shop And then I've been waiting for the repo
people checking the time, checking the clock.
Oh yeah, there's...
Yeah, here's a dino.
Raw.
Ew.
Look at him go.
Raw!
It's beautiful, isn't it?
Isn't it beautiful?
I love Fortnite.
It's like the perfect for you it is but i don't play the
game i just go on and buy skins that's fine oh i just
windows i like go in shop and then i i leave yeah you don't
window shop you actually shop i don't even windows shop yeah
i actually purchased my items so is uh the collab over now
or stream
oh my god in the future you can sell your account and oh
that is okay legally speaking we're joking guys but that is
a great idea you can't do that ever because obviously that
is against the terms of service yeah i would never propose
that like seriously i was just kidding we were all just
being tiki ha ha that it's a joke you know it's just but if
you're a collector then you know like I'm just it's just you
know you don't have the you can't afford this account
technically it's just my collection is so vast and rare in
general you know there's a leak about the next a cup the
next four upcoming collabs did you saw the leak I saw Kizna
I that's the only one I saw Kizna I regular show adventure
time part two and Marvel rivals oh my god yeah for no but
for In Venture Time Part 2, they're adding lemon grab.
Oh, no.
And Ice King.
They're adding lemon grab and Ice King.
I must have played it.
Oh, Finn and Jake.
Oh, that's it.
I'm surprised they didn't do, like, Princess Bubblegum.
Me too.
I think they did Marcelline, I'm pretty sure.
I don't know if they did do Princess Bubblegum, but I'm
pretty sure I saw Marcelline's guitar.
Oh, maybe.
Yeah, apparently.
Yeah, and then...
but uh people were like uh can you close the game he's
scaring me what's wrong with him so he's having a good time
oh i watch look at this i have the scooby-doo run
he's like a zoink scoop i could hear his little feet
scrambling yeah he's so loud look at his long legs i've been
to get in for the longest time, I'm not only missing the
Among Us backpack and then my collection is complete.
The Among Us backpack?
Yeah, the Among Us backpack and then it will be and then I
truly have the best account in the whole world.
Did you ever actually, did you play repo?
Yeah, I did.
I played like twice I think.
Yeah, I played it.
I played it.
I ain't no poser.
I played the game of skins I bought.
Yeah, that's why I don't have a Metal Gear skin because I
didn't want to be a poser, you know?
Oh, sure, sure, sure.
Okay, you're Slim Shady's biggest fan.
Name all the songs.
Sorry, what do you say I was coughing my lungs out?
Okay, I just name all the Snoop Dogg songs.
All the Snoop Dogs smoke my every day.
You know, smoke every day.
I'm so cool.
Are you okay?
You okay, Finn?
Yep, I'm good.
I'm so cool.
Yeah.
She's so cool, guys.
I am.
I'm so cool.
I'm part of the cool kids.
See, I could say it.
Say it.
I said it.
You didn't say it.
I'm not asking for the name of the song.
You say the name of the song.
I named it.
I named the song.
What are you...
It's not my fault.
Your ears didn't work.
everyone could tell what song it was discord cut it out no
no no you why would you say it really loud i'm really proud
i guess you all guess you have to rewind i thought you were
a big fan of snoop i am i am didn't say it really loud i did
i you just missed it it's not my fault i even said it twice
someone was just had bad listening skills i guess no no it's
because of discord someone
I didn't care.
You should say it really loud because I'm sure then if I
didn't hear, some people in chat didn't hear.
No, no, my chat heard it loud in here.
Right, chat?
I'm so.
You all heard it.
Guys, you guys hear?
Yeah, yeah.
You guys all heard it, right?
Do you hear?
Is that like every time you blew up the game?
No, I didn't hear.
I didn't hear.
You're just cherry picking.
You're cherry picking.
Okay.
Does it like play the sorry of how you boot up the game now?
No, he just waited so long.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so for this, I sort of forgot all the controls.
That's fine, you'll learn again.
That's how I do every day.
Every game.
Oh, yeah, I forgot this was what I was wearing.
Okay.
Wait, can you like share the game?
Oh, yeah.
I can't see anything.
Just watch from my stream with stream delay.
yeah like super oh yeah those guys are coming by the way i
was like yeah the one that's beating me up right now oh okay
oh yeah there they are oh do you think they know bra i'm a
crocodile how could they know i'm a crocodile wait they
didn't know just like walk around them just walk around them
wait they actually didn't know it's because you're not
wearing the gold outfit you got to put that on oh yeah how
do i put that on you remember go to your closet wait i don't
remember wait i don't remember they're scared oh they saw oh
no they didn't okay okay give me a sec i need to remember
how to put stuff on yeah okay camouflage yeah where's my
where's my hat The face thing you're wearing has been...
You think they'll see me now?
Yo, you're behind a tree.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
No, I actually like the...
Your hat, your crock hat, it has to be equipped as an item.
Yeah, how do I get the item again?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I have to hold it.
Yeah, you have to hold it.
It's so stupid.
Not anywhere where I'll get my gun out.
Where's my gun?
The other side.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
That's not a gun.
That's a knife.
Oh, you have a gun somewhere.
I do?
Where the fuck did I put my gun?
That's right.
The boss broke it.
You don't have a gun.
Oh, my God.
I actually have to stealth.
Yeah, you actually.
Okay.
call reinforcements oh they just did yeah oh okay so how do
i sneak do a sneak kill do you remember from your intensive
knowledge of metal gear i think you'll get it it's
instinctual i do not feel the instincts coming in right just
walk behind them and remember the basics of cqc okay and
what were the basics what's step one uh all right you got
the arms oh oh oh it's okay he thinks i'm part of the nature
okay now you can sneak up behind them no his buddy oh never
mind there's the other guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what's
what's step one of cqc see okay you don't even remember step
one of cqc it's literally right there you don't even
remember i remember everything i beat this game multiple
times oh my god oh my god i literally just showed up again
oh my god get up get up get up get up Okay!
Oh, okay.
It's fine.
There we go.
CQC.
Ah, there you go.
There we go.
All right, get the other guy.
Get the other guys.
CQC.
And then, oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
Get up.
I'm getting up.
Oh, my God.
He's just shaking me.
That's the way I'm heading over.
I'm heading over.
It's okay.
Oh, you could like totally roll dodge that or something, you
know?
Oh, yeah.
How do I roll it?
okay and then give me a sec uh wait what why does it says
change my camouflage I'm trying to cure myself oh there it
is wounds still open I'm suffering from a deep cut okay yeah
so I need to disinfect it yeah uh put you don't have to go
in order and then bandage and then there you go I did I
cured myself.
Yay!
And that's how you do it, guys.
And I should eat a little bit.
I'm a little hungry.
You're not that hungry.
Oh, you just ate your calorie mitt.
Okay.
It's okay.
See, it's okay.
I can find another one.
How do I shank them again?
Did you have the...
Oh, well, you could probably get on the ground and just kind
of stab them a little bit.
Yeah, but like, okay.
How do I stab him?
Oh, if you pick them up, they'll drop stuff.
Like, you pick them up and then you like drop them before
they wake up to drop them alright alright how do I shank him
uh I don't remember the delta controls if you're not okay
wait okay guys guys how do we shake I need to shank him well
first of all your knife is not equipped it's not oh is it oh
it is okay yeah now it is yeah oh there you go oh Yeah,
there you go.
There you go.
Yeah, see?
Yeah, just keep going.
Oh, he's dead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta make sure.
The other guys are gonna wake up, yeah.
All right, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, I got a double kill here.
Shagom, shagom.
There you go.
Kill everybody.
Yay.
That's like the most important part of this game is to kill
them all.
I like that.
Okay.
There's no consequences on my actions, right?
Is that why you're trying to tell me to kill them all?
Yeah, of course.
Okay.
I'll be.
Why would there be consequences?
I don't know.
Very insistent that I kill all of them.
And like, isn't Meta Gear supposed to be about stealth?
Yeah, but this is part of stealth, is it not?
Is it?
I did not realize stealth means kill everyone.
You know, I think I love stealth.
Exactly.
Stealth is pretty cool.
That didn't I realize I could just kill everyone.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm slowly remembering all these controls.
You know what's the worst part is that...
See, I told you to come back.
Also, I'm playing God of War right now, too.
So I need to remember...
So I'm going to get confused with God of War controls and
Metal Gear controls.
No.
Nobody ever does that.
Yeah?
It'll be fine.
Don't forget, you can also crouch walk.
Wait, how do I crouch walk?
Like this?
Like this.
Oh, okay.
I'm crouch walking.
Am I doing it?
You are, you are.
Okay.
Do you remember this area?
Uh, this is tutorial.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm back to where I started.
Wait, why am I not wearing my mask?
There you go.
I don't know.
That's your dumb decision to not wear it.
I thought this was a group effort.
Oh, this is where the frog was.
Oh, he's gone.
He left.
I'm here for the vibes.
There's another frog and another duck in this area then.
Oh, all right.
Well, we got to progress.
We got to save the world.
We got to save the world, man.
Yep, everybody.
Look at that.
She cares more about the frogs than, I don't know, than
America right now.
I've never cared more about America than in this game.
Oh, yeah.
If you care so much about America, name five seats.
Get him.
Why did you think you see him?
I did.
Oh.
There you go.
I love how, like...
Whoa, what?
That...
if you care so much about america name five americans five
americans right now yeah dokey bird is north american no
united states of america oh okay like you gotta really
clarify that because there's a north america and there's a
south america um oh like i just okay i forgot about the i
forgot about that you can fall off bridges yeah this is so
dangerous i mean how the fuck why did it make the hole so
big if i could just fall off of it are you gonna get those
mushrooms yeah but i can't remember how i'll get them you
just get them you get it attack it oh nice shank shank the
mushrooms shank shank all right it's all coming back slowly
coming back to me i just need to make sure i'm not hiding
okay can i cut the bridge no i don't think so yeah i just
want to make sure that nobody could follow me go to the left
see it can you oh i just saved your ass nice all right can i
throw him off the cliff you could yeah you can nice that's
my favorite type of kill all right you just gotta drag him
you gotta hold it and drag him oh you have to hold it oh my
god he's too heavy oh he had more stuff you've been skimping
out You only picked them up once.
Oh, my God.
Oh, apparently you can cut the rope on the bridge.
That's pretty nifty.
How did I throw him?
Oh.
Look, I'm just, okay.
Not like that.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm trying.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Yeah, like, oh, why are you doing that?
Why are you doing it?
You had him in the position.
I got this.
he wakes up anyway wait i can't pick him up anymore oh there
wait i can't pick him up anymore wait is it like two limit
okay i just got wait i can't pick him up he won't let me
tell you to like look down that area see there's a bunch of
stuff okay wait i'm just gonna i need him to get back up if
i if he could get back up i can throw him off stop on him
stop wake up wait how How do I stomp on him?
Oh, wait.
Well, well, that's...
I only equipped a knife?
Oh.
That shouldn't be there.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna wait until he wakes up.
Don't worry, sir.
I think it's...
I think it's the game just being a little funky.
No, no.
Don't worry.
Stomp is V.
Guys, I'm on a controller.
I don't think there's Vs on my controller.
A V.
Oh, apparently my...
Okay.
Oh, he said like, oh, you can...
Oh, oh, he's waking up.
Come on, come on, come on, wake up.
No, he's not.
Wake up, little boy.
He's asleep, baby.
Come on, I got something for you to show you.
Oh, it's okay, I can get back up.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
Or you could get back up.
Yeah, go that way.
Yeah, I'd go this way.
Your stamina is dropping.
That's okay, it's okay.
I went to the gym recently.
Oh, good.
Yay!
Oh, it's all right.
It's all right.
My stamina might be dropping, but it's okay.
It's okay.
You can just eat the mushrooms.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Easy.
Is he awake yet?
Come on, boy.
Wake up.
Wow, they actually, I don't know why he's not waking up.
Yeah.
Usually when you're on Thursday, yeah, they don't take so
long.
Maybe it's broken.
Something special to show you.
I think he's, like, stuck forever.
Well, oh, there you go.
Oh, nice.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, he's actually starting to wake up now.
He's got three stars instead of four.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, I'm going to move there.
Just a little bit more.
There you go, there you go.
Yay!
Oh, yeah.
Technically, I didn't murder him.
he just couldn't swim so it's it's not my fault it's exactly
that's what happened oh my stomach hungry your tummy is
growling all right yeah don't forget to do a codec call with
um sagan because you haven't talked to him yet sagan oh yeah
yeah how do i do codec calls again oh there you go oh there
you go there he is yep all right oh hello sir am i doing a
good job.
Oh, you're snake, aren't you?
And you're Siggant?
None other.
I heard that you're an expert on weapons, equipment, and
cutting-edge technology.
Close.
I am the expert on weapons, equipment, and cutting-edge
technology.
The expert.
I'm the guy that designed your trinket gun, active sonar,
and motion detector.
If you want to know anything about weapons, the guns I
haven't used yet.
All right, cool.
but that's our guy that's him yep too bad I haven't used any
of the things that he gave me sounds like a you problem no
no it sounds like a you problem you didn't coach me well
enough I'm not here to coach I'm here to vibe you're an
expert you are the metal gear solid expert and yet you're
not teaching me how to play metal gear don't compare me to
Siggins I don't want to be that good where am I supposed I'm
just gonna go this way remember we're meeting with uh with
uh I actually don't remember it's been too long go back to
where you found Sokolov oh okay I remember I got cardboard
oh I got cardboard box isn't that important okay hot oh my
god it's it's the box man I understood the metal gear yeah
That's the Metal Gear reference!
In your item.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there it is.
That's it.
The Metal Gear reference.
Okay, I don't need that.
I never use it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, uh, oh, that's not it.
Other side.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
You'll never know.
Yeah.
That's where I met him.
where is he good memories where is he good memories it's oh
what my box oh i'm here so this is like the one um game
where like the box is kind of useless oh in most cases then
what's the point of having the box because it's iconic you
have to have it but like you're in the jungle why would
there be a box i don't know someone ordered amazon amazon
goes Oh, it's her!
I don't know who she is, but like...
Then how do you know it's her?
Adam couldn't make it.
Because it's her!
Don't forget to press R1.
Who are the patrons?
It's my Amazon delivery!
Oh!
Did I got it right?
Yeah, you got it right.
See, that's what you know.
I'm part of the crew.
I did it.
She did it.
she's gangsta she shot sideways i know is your answer this
is awesome wait but she didn't say the yippity duda yeah
you're just gonna forget that part wait then she she's not
part of the patriots no who are the patriots oh oh she looks
like um john rising r1 r1 r1 r1 i'm r1ing i'm running i know
i admit this is not bunny whatever guidance we were playing
bunny guidance oh oh my guide snake your eyes are whoa wait
got him going
bunny guidance
I popped by your stream and the first thing I saw was you
making one of the girls drink beer No, they only drink water
I would never make them they're already drunk they can't
drink any more beer Oh, yeah drink water.
That's irresponsible Oh, wait, why is he smoking after
Because he's He saw the booze and he goes done Yeah Yeah yes
why why because i can do things he can like what like be hot
used to be a code breaker for the nsa i was four years ago i
defected to the oh my god is she the mom of the girl who
needs to breathe through her skin and that's why she's in
the bikini close yeah she's quiet she's pretty quiet yeah
she's pretty quiet yeah That was impressive Bet you've never
seen that technique in the West The gangster style It's a
Chinese type 17 Oh
Oh voice volume is quiet guys Alright don't worry I'll
adjust it Oh Voice acting in this game is important 45 huh
he's gonna start being a little freak polished to a mirror
sheen oh yeah and the interlock with the frame is tightened
for added precision he's such a nerd I know look at them go
damn that's so hot women I don't care gun nearly every part
of this gun has been expertly crafted and customized the way
he's manhandling Oh.
Where'd you get something like this?
I grabbed it from a Western munitions armory.
It probably used to belong to one of your officers.
And there are more where that came from.
You had this with you, didn't you?
Better take this too.
What's that?
Oh, is that my disguise?
Yeah.
Oh, I just need my glasses.
You're gonna be a...
scientist i'm gonna be a nerd yes he's being forced to
continue guys i haven't up the volume yet because if i do
i'll it'll like pause the cut scene they've got a whole army
of scientists they're developing new weapons security is
tight but if you do it now i'll just be quiet oh oh it won't
let me tab out never mind oh
it was like you want me to skip the cut scene
First, you'll need to head north through the jungle.
Wait, can I actually...
Oh, I can't.
Pause.
It says pause.
Oh, pause.
Pause.
Wait.
Wait, didn't pause.
It's not pausing.
Yeah, it's not pausing.
Guys, it didn't pause for me.
I'm too scared to keep doing it.
Yeah, just wait until it's over so you don't skip it on
accident.
Make your way through the warehouse and you'll come out just
south of the lab.
I love this part.
And just what are you doing there?
Oh, I'm modifying.
I'm putting a silencer.
In close range combat, a knife can sometimes be more useful
than a gun.
By doing this, I'll be able to hold a knife at the same time
and still keep the gun steady.
That way, I can instantly switch between a gun battle and a
knife fight.
It's the essential parts of CQC.
The CQC?
Oh, close.
Quarter's combat.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Oh, he not fine.
It's a jungle out there.
The Russian jungles.
Oh my gosh.
What Russia is most known for.
Yeah.
Gators and jungles.
I have to get back.
I can't be gone for too long.
They'll start to suspect something.
Don't worry.
I will not be surprised to gojima just adds a lion in this
game.
Can you guess what other animals are in this game?
The famous Russian lions.
Mm-hmm.
All right, then.
I'll do something special for you.
Ah!
R1!
You don't need the R1.
I'll stand watch until dawn.
Now be a good boy and lie down.
Oh!
yes yes man a little mermaid what's the matter you well
enough to trust you I'm also in my gator suit to know me to
trust me I think that would be uncomfortable I don't know if
I can trust anybody no he's trust his shoes he lost his mama
he lost his mama so he can't trust nobody no boy well
oh all right now i can do the volume
all right whenever you save the game and quit you'll go to
sleep oh sleeping allows you to gain back stamina naturally
depending on how long you sleep you may also oh so if i
don't like if i don't play the game for a while i go get
full hp yeah but also um your food does like expire too oh
yeah so if you don't play for a while your food will go bad
oh i see okay let me turn up the volume a little bit more
all right guys let me know if the volume's okay now are you
playing controller or controller but i can swap between the
two oh okay oh so time passes like real time yeah so
basically i'm like snake got to russia and it took a
two-week break pretty much he was just asleep I needed it
because he like went back to work immediately.
Got to heal the bones.
What are you doing?
I knew I never trust, never trust her.
Never trust a woman.
Yeah, never trust women.
Yeah.
Especially not in a bond again.
Oh, you can R1 again.
Wow!
R1!
Oh
What's the matter we're surrounded I See four of them.
Oh my god, it's the red berets.
It's the Ocelot crew.
Yeah, the Ocelot unit.
See I remember
That musy's close If I can smell him.
Of course you can smell it.
Do you own any dojins based off of this bearing?
Uh, no.
It's not.
It's more difficult to find than you would think.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
I'm not surprising.
I have more dojins of snake and snake than snake.
Ah, yes, the snake says...
okay love is very important
like i have a lot of safe for work metal gear dogen's don't
get me wrong but i also but for like you know not oh wait
yeah they're coming out wait wait yeah they're coming in now
they won't know oh wait i could someone said call it sing it
uh singing
Those rifles the Ocelots are using aren't AK-47s, are they?
No.
They kind of look like AKMs, but they're different.
They're in Russia.
You know, AK-47s were invented by Russians.
It's vertical type 4 grips.
And the muzzle suppressor is bigger.
Oh my God.
But they're not AK-47s.
Hungary has a unique modified version of the AKM called the
AMD-63.
So it's not really quite okay.
I'll open it up more.
imported some of those prototypes if they're using a carbine
version of the AMD 63 like I'm thinking then they could be a
serious threat those things oh yeah I think they want you to
call about the box yeah yeah yeah he's too busy talking
about they're nerdy out about guns right now and you're that
much more likely to get seriously hurt keep your eyes open
don't worry I can call him again so true oh okay all right
more fun facts guys more fun facts
you like my okay cool okay so they also have shotguns
yeah they they sometimes if you don't call very often
there's like a backlog oh my god okay so they also have guns
but Oh, and scorpions?
Okay, how many fucking guns do they have?
Like, I saw four of them.
This is literally his job.
Doki, this is his job.
Okay, okay, that's the fourth gun.
There's no way they're gonna carry a mysterious fifth gun.
Because we saw four guys.
There might be more.
Oh, okay, and also they're carrying grenades.
Okay, cool.
You could get burned too.
If somebody throws a grenade at you, get away from it.
Do you not see my cool-ass box?
Oh my god
Wait to attach just wait that's how true was very important
we go wait that was actually That was wait okay, oh no
You're you if your suppressor breaks then you have to find
another one.
Okay, okay, okay.
That's good.
That's good to know Okay, um, wait also I want to see if I
can actually just raise the Audio of the doc.
Nope never mind You could you could Turn down like the other
stuff.
I don't know.
I'm gonna turn down.
Oh shit, not all the way down.
I'm gonna turn down the sound effect just in case.
And then...
That and then...
Yeah, that should be fine.
Yeah, that should be fine now.
And then I'll... I think that's the only thing, right?
Yeah.
Alright.
New volume time.
Alright, let me know guys if this is better.
Sound guy.
I think our usual sound guy is like...
A rev.
Oh, they...
Yeah, what is this box doing here?
It's so...
They're so weird, isn't it?
What a weird...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, my God!
How did you know?
Get him... Oh, shit!
I'm the way I got his legs!
There you go.
Oh, it's the shotgun!
It's the shotgun!
Oh, get me out of here!
Get me out of here!
Okay, there we go.
A classic.
How did they know?
say no how many times have i said that before you have the
gun now yeah yeah i'm equipping it which one is is it the m
oh the non-lethal okay yeah yeah yeah it's lethal time it's
lethal time let's go all right here you go it's fine it's
fine wait did his own grenade yeah yeah yeah so i'll just
stay here There you go.
Yeah, I'll just stay here.
He has to keep walking into the room, right?
Oh.
Reload.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, five enemies left.
Yep, five enemies left.
Come on.
They have to come here.
Not all of them are going to come over here.
There's a guy on the roof, too.
Yeah, we'll just wait.
We'll just wait.
Unless he came down.
I don't know.
There's three bodies here.
okay all right that means i can eat now okay do i need to
eat oh wait i don't need no you're full yeah i'm full come
on i'm like playing valorant right now i gotta hold the ink
she's camping she's camping i'm camping i'm holding head
height holding head height all right I want to grab some
loot.
Rob them of all their worth.
They don't have anything.
But they're like...
No, you have to put them down.
They put them down.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Yeah.
Alright, I know some of you guys, you skimp out sometimes,
too.
So I'm going to...
I'm going to shake you up.
I'm going to shake you.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll shake you for items.
Alright.
Okay, you didn't skimp out.
Alright, and then...
Alright, put them in my...
little room, my little murder room.
Yay!
Oh, a ration.
Oh, that's good.
That's food.
Yeah, food is fun.
Oh, yeah, but I won't put him in my murder room.
Oh, that was a suppressor.
Oh, nice.
Okay, so my suppressor can break now.
Oh, yeah.
Definitely can break.
Alright, now, now, it's okay if they break.
Well, you only have one.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
I think you need to leave.
Yeah.
Go find this.
Why did he not come to my little room?
My little murder room.
It's a good question.
Wait, I got this.
Wait, watch this.
Now I'm confident.
What did you do?
Oh.
Oh my god.
What did I do?
The murder room.
Right here.
I'm so safe.
all right here we go the best part is that you don't even
need to kill these guys because if you took them out with
the trank they would um stay down the whole time but oh
really yeah we're all right there you go all right one more
oh there he is yeah i told you on the roof well not one more
there's like all right he's definitely dead there's two more
All right.
Where's the last guy?
Where the fuck is he?
Hello?
They're around.
You have two guys.
There's not one last guy.
Last guy.
Where are you?
Two guys.
There's one.
All right.
Last guy.
He's on the other side.
He's on this side?
No, no.
I think he's like, yeah.
If you go up the ladder, you can probably find him easily.
Oh, yeah.
That's true.
That's smart.
Yeah.
all right where is this last guy hot ground i have high
ground advantage now but i don't see him pretty sure he's oh
he's like over in the forest on the other side yeah let me
yeah well shake this guy up yeah oh there's something down
there oh yeah there is yeah all right i won't get fall
damage i don't want to break my shin no there's no fall
damage oh there isn't no Oh my god, go just jump down!
Just jump.
From any height, you'll always live.
Oh, that's cool.
That's good to know.
There's no way you'd lie to me.
Alright.
Oop.
Alright, last guy.
Come on.
Come out, come out, wherever you are.
Oh my god.
Snake, you gotta work on your arms.
It takes so long to pick these people up.
What are you talking about?
He's just got little alligator arms.
Yeah, but alligators are strong.
With their mouths.
Bro, those arms are fucking picking them up.
Picking those strong-ass bodies up.
Oh, well.
Yeah, I'll pick this up.
Oh, mind detector.
Wait, there's minds?
Oh, no.
He's like, okay, yeah, you're going to the right way.
He's like, right behind that wall.
Oh.
you he was right behind the wall okay which wall though
there we go wow easy the wall you were standing in front of
the controller all right that was why you weren't on
controller how do you think i got those headshots that was
like bam bam quick headshots i've got headshots before with
a controller i did too i did too but then i really realize
it was quicker.
All right, we did it.
It's so easy.
Am I okay?
Why am I 5%?
Oh, it's just my stealth.
Yeah, that's your camel.
Oh my God, look at me.
Like little raptor arms.
I know.
It's so cute.
Yeah.
Yo.
All right.
I guess I leave now, right?
Oh, wait, wait.
Now I can call him.
I want to show away my cool box.
Oh yeah, show the box.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, my ass is sticking out.
My dumpy.
Oh, it is.
Snake's dumpy.
So that's why they always notice.
That's why.
Yeah, yeah.
Sounds like the Cobra units members names came from.
Oh my God.
Don't you not see my cool ass boxes?
Yeah.
For unbearable torment, the pain.
The pain.
For true oblivion, the end.
The end.
the fury oh my gosh the joy joy the joy it's another name
for the boss because of the joy she feels in battle I
suppose during the war she had a partner named the sorrow
yeah this is so edgy you see my box You're like really
behind.
What do you mean?
He literally showed up like in the beginning of this
chapter.
Yeah, and that was nighttime.
That was an hour ago.
You have been streaming for an hour.
Like 20, 30 minutes of that was Fortnite.
So shut the hell up.
That was 30 minutes ago.
Oh, yeah.
I remember the Alamo.
Remember the Alamo.
You know, I'm no one gonna call you anymore.
You don't fucking know anyway.
I'm gonna call my dad.
Hey, dad.
Oh, I thought he was gonna say, good job, boy, for killing
all of them.
Oh, hey, dad, I killed all of them.
Is that cool?
Oh, okay.
See, he's to the point.
He only says one thing.
SIG still has like fucking 20 chapters left.
He's telling you where to go.
You've got an M1911A1.
Sure I do.
I'm gonna go to get some water while you...
Always listen to SIG talking.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a real gem of an automatic pistol.
But aren't you gonna need more than just one little handgun?
Not at all.
When you're in a tight spot or fighting in close quarters,
sometimes a handgun works better than a rifle.
And if I equip a knife at the same time, time i can
instantaneously switch over oh that's the same thing i told
the other girl that 45 you've got there is a lot different
from the original though it looks like it's more than a
little first of all the feeding ramp is polished to a mirror
it's not going to have he's like nerding the out his leg
finally i can tell more tell more people about my gun the
frame itself yeah he's really proud proud of that technique
that he definitely invented to himself the front strap part
of the frame has been checkered to make it dig into the hand
that prevents any slipping the sight systems original too
it's a we can't snake you really love guns giving its
superior target sighting capability the regular hammer has
been replaced with a ring hammer that enhances the cocking
control and increases the hammer down speed they also rework
the grip safety to accommodate the ring hammer like they
eliminated it altogether this is a tool for pros the thumb
safety and the slide stop are extended to allow for more
precise handling the base of the trigger guard is whittled
down so you can use a high grip and the trigger itself is a
long type for easy finger like a true american did you get
the box yet how does he know how heavy no no he's he's
nerding out about his gun that's about right it's the
obsession yeah the main spring housing has been changed to a
flat type to increase grip well you look you play you know
lsbs this is what you're into when firing i on top of that i
they added caulking serrations to the i don't know what i
don't know what what sub what are the gun types i'd be like
which what's the which was the machine gun guys which
I'll be like, guys, I'll be like, get the, get the machine
gun.
I'm like, guys, where's the machine gun?
Okay, this one has to be it.
This one, third time's a try.
Okay, okay, third time's a try.
Snake, what are you doing?
Oh, yeah, we did it!
I'm in the box!
I was just looking at it, and suddenly I got this
irresistible urge to get inside.
no not just an urge oh it was a destiny destiny to be yeah i
was pouring gina box yeah and then when i put it on my inner
peace i can't put it into words i feel it's like he's back
in the womb you know like this yeah like i'd found the key
to trocade calm down snake you said that the box was
important in metal gear this is it Box then you'll know what
I mean Man, I don't want to know what you mean Bro Is
everyone but me that is hooked up with a major strange?
Yeah, he's like a cat He's like, I don't know what I don't
know Wait until you learn about the love box Whoa The love
box The love box Oh, oh, like if I wear the box I can't, if
I wear the mask and can't wear the box?
Oh, wait.
Do I leave or is there another entrance here?
Yeah, keep going.
Yeah, keep going where you're going.
Yeah.
They'll never know.
Yeah, why would they know?
I'd go to the left.
Yeah.
There's like a gate over there.
Oh, there it is.
Cutscene activated.
Oh, oh, is that my potential future boyfriend?
Pew.
Pew, pew.
Oh, my God.
He's using the snake technique oh shit
oh my god he made my bullet into a necklace oh my god i
understand you get it right i get it i get it now wow wow
yeah he does that a fee but female he's like i've never
touched a woman before this is wearing perfume this is
wearing perfume He has to eliminate the competition.
I see you've got yourself a single-action army.
That's right.
Oh my god, he's gonna say it.
He's gonna say it.
Oh, he's gonna go back.
Well, it wouldn't have happened if you hadn't been showing
off.
What did you say?
It's a nice gun.
I'll give you that.
Oh, oh, oh.
Graving's giving me no tactical attention.
Why do I have to do it?
Unless you were planning to auction it off.
Look, it looks sick, okay?
What?
Oh, because he's too in love.
He's like, I can't kill you.
Oh, even the gun knows.
Oh, it's jammed.
Yeah, kick his butt.
Oh, my God.
Oh shit!
What the?
That's a tired of the face.
Six shots.
You have to get a feel for how many you have left.
Look at nerd.
He counts bullets.
Oh yes he does.
This is a high class weapon.
It's not meant for shooting people.
What is it meant for?
But it's a gun.
Okay.
This one is like a collector's guy.
Because it's our position.
The gun rocks.
He's so...
Don't.
Why?
He's still young.
No, he won't.
Well, maybe well.
He doesn't regret it.
Nah.
There's like four to five more games with him.
Oh, she's so cool.
I know she's so awesome.
Do a flip.
Oh, shit.
She did a flip basically off of a guy's face.
So, you know.
He's got to protect her's future boyfriend.
He doesn't know it yet.
But like...
Oh, I think he knows.
No, the Ocelot doesn't know it yet.
But they're going to get together.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Yeah, especially after the Cold War ends.
And then Ocelot's gonna move to America to see...
Oh, we have to go back, right?
Or here?
They go here or...
I think...
Well...
Or then another gate opened after she did the flip.
Oh,
my stomach, Hungy.
Oh, you're Hungy.
I'm Hungy.
It shouldn't be the other way.
That's so great.
Yeah.
And then, like, when the Cold War ends, war oh yeah there is
when the cold war ends uh ocelot's gonna move to america and
then like uh be like a a living room live in roommate with
snake and then uh and they will be like oh they were
roommates and they're like yeah roommates yeah yeah welcome
to the swamp oh sorry swamps of russia accidentally shot the
snake all right oh i can swim now right yeah you can swim
just watch out for gators fucking swim wait how how long
does it take to kill a gator with a gun oh god i don't i
don't know i don't remember it takes a bit yeah you could
grenade it oh i can grenade them yeah oh that's the stun
grenade okay i got to equip it no i had a lot of grenades i
robbed all of Oh, okay.
There it is.
Up there.
Yeah, that's the first one.
All right.
I'm going to give them a little gift.
Yeah.
Say hello to my little friend.
Oh, he just left.
Oh, oh, there you go.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
There you go.
Look, see.
Say hello to my little friend.
Now get there.
Get the meat.
Where is the meat?
Oh, my God.
There's a lot of them.
Yeah, they give you a lot of meat.
oh there you go and then oh i gotta cure myself wait how did
i oh i got a leech attached how the fuck did i get the leech
out cigarette yeah the cigar okay there you go i was gonna
you'll hear them they kind of they kiss you they go oh shit
in front of stream you can you can get them later though or
like you can get them off later it's not a biggie okay nice
holy shit that fish yeah oh he's coming over he's like i
want to join him what happened oh my god watching him
dissolve in front of you wait where's my food oh there it is
you're gonna die you're gonna die am i yeah look at your
stamina oh my god i am oh god oh god that's fine
everything's fine oh there's another some of the gator eat
some of the gator oh yeah i should Oh, I got another leash.
Can I get this leash out of?
Cigar.
Alright.
Gotta eat my crocodile.
Oh, that's why.
Yummy, yummy.
This works.
Oh, and the snake as well.
Might as well.
Oh, what am I doing?
Sometimes you get a little diagram, a little video.
Oh, shit.
Visual representation of you.
You.
Oh.
Oh my god, I'm a fucking animal.
I eat all of this raw?
Bro, what the fuck is wrong with this?
Do you know you eat too much raw meat?
You can actually have like brain worms or some shit.
That's if you eat like human brains, okay?
Okay, I'm pretty sure like, don't there's mad cow disease.
Isn't that when you eat too much raw meat?
That's like if you eat human brains, you can get the
equivalent of mad cow disease.
Oh, okay, so it's not gonna eat raw meat.
then i thought like it does something because wasn't there a
guy that like almost died because all he did was eat raw
meat because he's like that's the manly thing to do and then
he almost like and he got into the hospital probably i'm
dead i don't need to worry about it oh that crocodile wants
to come over oh yeah the liver king yeah that guy oh yeah
all he did was eat like raw meat and then he like was like
i'm not on steroids and then like he was actually on
steroids like oh but he's the liver king he doesn't need to
what yay more crocodile meat guys more croc meat yay
oh made it to the other side zero casualties oh there's a
that's the yeah watch out yeah so can i shoot it um you
could just crawl under it I'm in or you can just the mine
thing for it.
I think it's like yeah No Because in other games you can
just shoot.
Oh, there we go.
Oh That is oh, I thought it was like an explosive call.
Nah Hello snake are you there?
Yeah, oh my god every number Did you make it without any
trouble?
No one saw me.
Eba.
So you're back with vulgan?
Yeah, no matter of speaking.
What about the boss?
Yeah, she's here, too be careful thanks i will the boss and
i get along pretty well though i guess we traders have a lot
why doesn't she betraying her country why do you do it
weren't you born and raised in america yes in a small rural
town i know she a country girl she a country guy yeah howdy
howdy and howdy and one I'd found I'd lost faith in the
things I'd been taking for granted What did you see?
What was it that made you want to change sides?
What did you see?
Try me.
I saw the universe.
What?
Not the actual universe.
The universe as the intelligence.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, bro, we should burn her.
Yeah, witch.
environment and by the times that sounds like what the boss
was saying there's a world of difference between this
country and america but it's only a difference of position a
difference of perspective coming here made me realize
something half of what i've been told was a complete she's a
female her age is 28.
was a conveniently constructed yeah she's also had the truth
is boob surgery oh i can tell you yeah you'll learn that
later she didn't say the lula d la boo she could be she
could be a liar she could be yeah because i asked her what
is the code and then she just shot people as a distraction
yeah and then she was like that's your answer no it's not
yeah it's not our answer is 142.52 Okay, you have to
memorize it.
It's okay, I have a number, see?
One, four, two, point.
I'm going to call her again.
Yeah.
It doesn't seem desperate, right?
No, she would never think that.
I think she's the one desperate for you.
Don't call after the first day, you know?
That's a lie, right?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you mean that it's where I killed 80% of the population.
Crocs are now endangered.
Yeah, the endangered species after snakes showed up in
Russia.
Wait, I don't remember, hold on chat, because you get the
croc hat, like it's DLC.
What is the thing that, what is the, what is it?
I can't remember.
Oh my God, it's just all crocodile.
You have to eat all of that before stream ends, is it the
other croc hat what what is the item or what it's another
croc hat okay there's more than one croc hat yeah because in
the original um you would find the croc hat in this area oh
also yeah yeah okay so it's a different one okay okay i
increased the volume a little bit more sound guy what yeah
they said the casting value was too low Oh, they do talk
quietly sometimes.
Yeah, the audio balancing is a bit like on and off because
it's like different between cutscene volume and...
Okay, so now you have dogs.
I have a dog!
Oh, they're not good dogs, are they?
They're not good dogs.
Oh, they're not my dogs.
I guess...
uh oh yeah you just crawl under that i can crawl under that
oh i can't i thought of the shank it oh well it's like
electrified also there's like mines around here so be
careful oh actually why did i tell you that oh i see it i
see it's that you just if you crawl over it you pick it up
oh that's good to know yeah oh i could just crawl all the
time Oh my god, they're just giving me free bombs.
Look at him go.
Look at all these bombs for free.
Bombs for free, baby.
Yeah, in this economy, too?
There you go.
I shouldn't have said anything, you guys.
Oh, there's the dog.
Yeah, there's the dog.
Oh.
You wouldn't.
Goodbye, doggo.
Is your suppressor?
Oh, okay, never mind.
It's because the dog's wheeled.
No, yeah, I have a suppressor on.
Don't worry.
The dog ratted.
Ratted you out.
No, you didn't.
I'm still okay.
I'm in there.
Camo is only...
Oh, now it's 80.
Yeah, yeah, see?
I'm still okay.
Still okay.
You getting nice and muddy.
Oh.
Oh, there you go.
What was that?
I can't believe you know hesitated that dog.
Yeah, but it's not my dog.
If it was my dog, it'd be fine.
Oh, my God.
His head is horrible.
It looks like you blew his brains out.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my ammo is full.
That's your suppressor ammo.
Oh, yeah, I've not been using that.
No, you haven't.
Where is the...
dog will remember this well well the dog you're gonna sink
you're gonna die oh no oh no oh no you're gonna sink and
you're gonna die it's fine it's fine oh i could tranquilize
the dog man why did you yeah i'm my because he was so fast
to kill the dog his blood is now on your hands no i i don't
i don't take responsibility no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no tranquilize you can tranquilize
literally anything in this game it's on my phone that you're
on her hands because I think that I wouldn't have shot the
dog I wouldn't have shot that dog at the moment you shot no
hesitation no no no we looked at the dog we looked at the
dog for at least two seconds so I did hesitate technically I
think Chai is saying that I'm innocent and it's all your
fault what's wrong oh there we go I have to be okay your
suppressor is not on your suppressor is not on it's fine I
just need him is he not dead tanking it oh my god he's
tanking it okay now he's dead I mean eventually they're
gonna get like shields and bigger things oh my god he's like
it's okay guys I'm still alive there we go see there you go
bro what damn that guy was insane for tanking all that that
that's he look at all maybe the boss yeah he i think yeah
there's there's he has to be big boss yeah he ate those
bullets and said oh wait it's somebody's birthday uh whose
birthday is it guys dr s shenanigans happy birthday happy
birthday to you yeah wait whose birthday was it You should
know.
Wait, who's birthday?
You said it so fast.
Is it Dr. Shenanigans?
Happy birthday, Dr. Shenanigans.
Happy birthday, dear shenanigans.
Happy birthday.
That's doctor to you.
Oh, sorry.
Dr. Shenanigans.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah.
Not so great.
It's all right.
We have to get rid of...
Okay, wait.
How do I put suppressor on again?
I don't know.
Do you...
You don't have any.
do i not i looted a suppressor oh did it break and that's
why yeah oh i see i'll go this way okay now that i know that
we can tranquilize the dogs because not because chat told me
not because mint told me i will tranquilize the dogs now oh
right right i gotta bring
you have no suppressor that's okay see he was the only one
wait that's a that's a turret how what do i do with that yes
but uh it's not like on or anything like oh okay then that's
fine yeah you should blow up the the helicopter though oh i
can how do i blow it up did i throw a grenade uh you throw
you can use it maybe it well i would be good yeah you could
use the turret if you wanted oh can i turn around with the
turret oh wait Oops.
Wait, oops.
What's that sound?
You hear that?
Yeah, sound is suspicious.
Sounded not.
It sounded like you were triggering something.
Get it.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Oh, shit, that's not fine.
Now more guys are gonna come?
Oh, shit, that's not good.
Oh, shit, that's not no.
You know, you could also use your other thing because it has
a suppressor.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, that sucks.
Yeah, that sucks.
Yeah, but that's a tranquilizer, though.
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa.
Who is that?
Oh, that's me.
Who's that?
Okay.
Are you...
Someone's back on, uh, mouse.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he's still alive?
Okay, there we go.
Oh, you're so lucky.
Oh, damn.
Oh, no.
Okay, give me a sec.
I got bullet lodged in my fucking wound.
How do I get a bullet out?
With your knife.
I got a knife?
Oh, okay, there you go.
All right, knife.
This infects.
You're bleeding.
bleeding oh there we go oh oh we gotta watch another little
movie yeah we got another movie
oh okay that gun is weak as fuck if it didn't go through my
body if it's like not that deep where i can just cut it out
and use oh okay no snake is just built like a machine
different yeah he's like a little wall that guy is yeah his
muscle density is like 300 percent Like, if you could
just...
Alright, there you go.
Bro, he gotta bite something if he's doing this.
No, he doesn't.
This is why he's...
He's one of the disciples of the boss.
Yeah, but a failed disciple, though.
He didn't make the cut.
Y'all remember that.
How was it that you not make the cut?
Yeah, she disowned him.
Well, you know, that's just because he's just a babe.
Oh my god, I hate this gun Oh my god What is the word?
Yeah, I forgot to mention that Oh my fucking god Okay, okay
This gun fucking sucks You can equip their knife And CQC all
of them, you know Oh, you have the knife equipped Never
mind, you're kidding Oh my god What
Okay Okay, do they go back up?
Do they get back up?
Yeah, he'll get back up eventually.
How do I shink?
Okay.
Oh, uh-oh.
Someone just saw you.
Right there.
Wow!
You have to get his head!
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, Doki, I played the whole game with this thing.
Okay, that shit sucks.
That shit sucks.
Keep killing him!
Alright.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's see.
I need ammo.
Give me your ammo.
Oh my god, that has to be it.
Oh yeah, that's it.
That's it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You could kill this guy too if you want.
I'm gonna...
I need his ammo too.
Yeah.
There you go.
Oh, that's a suppressor.
Nice.
Patrol here.
Come on.
What are you doing?
Come on!
How are you still alive?
Because you're just doing tiny little scratches.
Okay, he's dead.
Oh my god.
Okay, you better be dead.
Because there's still two.
Oh, there's one.
There's that guy too.
That's him just going to shank him in the ass.
Yeah.
There you go.
Oh my god.
It looks like he's doodied himself.
You had Taco Bell last night.
Oh, no.
All right.
I love this music.
See, this is why I need a headshot.
I'll re-equip your suppressor as well.
Is it not on?
How do I equip it?
Is it, like, in my inventory?
Triangle?
Oh.
Nope, that's roll.
Oh, I can roll this entire time?
Yeah, I told you you could roll through stop?
I was like, dang, you should, like, dodge roll those
bullets, but you didn't.
Yeah, I'm just built different.
What can I say?
Alright.
Oh, it's on the quick select?
Okay.
Where is it?
Oh, yeah, go hover over the gun.
Oh, see?
Oh, wait, go back to it.
See, attach, detach suppressor.
Oh, it's on this gun.
Oh.
No, why did you take?
No, no, there's two different ones.
There's two different They have two different suppressors So
put the suppressor Yeah There Put the suppressor back on the
That's the tranquilizer though But I want to I know Press
the The chute one No They have different suppressors Because
they're two different types of guys Okay so they have to Do
it here No you don't Okay Okay so Okay Put that on And then
put it on The suppressor too Yeah And then Yay!
We did it!
We figured it out, guys.
We figured it out.
It was so easy.
Wait, can I get on the helicopter?
You can blow it up.
I would suggest that.
Okay, how do I blow it up with a grenade?
Put some claymores under there and then shoot them.
You're right.
Where's my claymore?
They're in your backpack.
Alright.
Oh, there.
Oh, no, that's just my crocodile.
Oh, there it is.
there it is yeah i'll go put the claymore down put them put
like five of them down all right uh actually will this work
or do you need the c3 or the c4 wait where is it c3 is it c3
or c4 i can't remember oh well she's doing it i'm doing it
c3 or c4 maybe the c2 and the c1's as well yeah yeah what
try that we'll see okay am i oh oh somebody noticed oops oh
what i'm just gonna see this is why i use m and k i'm gonna
shoot his ass too oh they're getting stronger yeah no it's
because i shot i ash shot him see this is exactly why i used
i'm using I used MNK.
Oh, take those back.
Take those back.
Oh, it didn't work?
No, no, no.
Okay.
Yeah, just grab them again.
All right.
The other one, too.
Backing up.
And there's a, there's a, what's it called?
And there's like a...
Oh, there's one in the house?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I got him.
I'm going to try and grab my stuff back.
He must have some of my ammo.
He might.
I think there's a guy to your right.
Yeah.
Nah.
I don't think so.
No.
Okay.
Yeah?
Oh, hey.
If you blow this up, their comms will be bad.
Oh, that's good.
Okay, I'll throw a grenade in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll be fine, right?
If I throw a grenade in there?
Should be fine.
I'm going to stay up here and then...
Boop.
Do you need to know?
Oh.
Is it broken?
Yeah, I told you there was a grenade.
there was a guy over there.
Wait, is it broken though?
It looks like it.
Can't tell.
No, I think it's still...
It doesn't look broken.
Oh, no, it's still working.
Yeah.
Weird.
Well, I thought you could blow this up.
Why isn't it work?
Yeah.
Maybe it's a TNT also for this, too.
I think so, too.
Oh, there he is.
There you go.
I think that's their food shed here, so if you blow this one
up.
Oh, yeah, free food!
And then if you if you blow this up then they'll be hungry
and they won't like work as well oh nice okay oh no this is
their weapons win never mind nice but yeah same same kind of
idea you just want to like blow these up you want to blow
this up okay so they will have lack of guns well i think
it's the tnt though isn't it oh i blew up the door yeah i
don't think i don't think we're anywhere
I do have TNT, yeah.
Wait, apparently I do have TNT.
I do?
Wait, when did you get it?
I don't even remember when I got TNT.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there it is, yeah.
How many TNTs do I have?
Uh, we'll build comms first.
Put it in your inventory.
You have five.
How do I activate it?
Uh, right click?
Or like, do, yeah.
Oh, it'll tell you.
It'll tell you.
Give me a sec.
I'm hungry.
Hey, this works.
Oh, aim?
What?
You missed how it tells you.
Didn't?
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
X.
Oh, I have to be close.
I don't... No, you don't have to be close.
What do you mean?
You have to be close.
It's an explosive.
Oh, my God!
It didn't work!
That's door.
You were reading the door.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
See if you can get like more.
Or yeah, put it on.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The fucking door got me.
It has to be close.
Yeah.
We did it.
Now there should be a shed that hides like more food and
more ammo.
Like more TNT and stuff, too.
Unless you already grabbed it.
Alright.
Someone said, why, why?
Someone said, only food shed you can destroy.
Sure?
Oh, you can't destroy these ones?
Are you sure?
But the comms.
The food.
Oh, it's this one.
That's the food shed.
Yeah.
Let's start a famine.
Calorie, man.
Alright.
Let's go.
Oh, wait.
There's one more.
Oh, there's rats.
Oh, my God.
Let's go.
Alright.
Okay, the south side here instead of next to.
Oh, comms is five.
That's right.
Yeah, you guys are.
I'm getting my games wrong.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
I killed the rats, too.
Yeah.
Free rat meat.
Rat meat.
All right.
That should be everything.
No, go inside, too.
Go inside.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Knock, knock.
I thought it jumped through the window.
It's easier.
it jump through the window see what's in here just a bed oh
nice okay there's bullets that's another suppressor that's
not bullets oh i can oh okay i can jump through okay i just
need to roll through the window see if there's anything on
the roof too is there i think so there's a ladder right
there yeah i know i think they put things upstairs why would
they put things on the roof like what's the point.
Because they're little silly guys.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I forgot.
They are little silly guys.
Oh, it's like uniform and water.
Wait, what's this?
That's a new camo.
Oh, my God.
I could be a scientist.
I forgot.
You'll never know now.
Now they won't know.
I'm part of the team.
Nah, they're gonna know.
They won't know.
Yeah, I think they'll know.
I'm part of the team.
Look, I even have glasses on.
Oh, I'm hungry again.
Well, you're too hungry.
That's why I don't know.
I'm always hungry.
because you're using so much stamina how no i'm not i'm just
casually jogging around you're being i'm casually jogging i
don't even know where to go i guess i go this way yeah look
i'm just i'm just a scientist they don't shoot a scientist
i'm unarmed it's part of the uh what's it called it's
probably like doctors without borders you never shoot the
doctor oh they follow that for sure Yeah, yeah, it's like,
like, you know how, like, journalists, they can document
wars and stuff, and you don't shoot a journalist?
I'm a scientist.
I'm a doctor without borders.
Yippee!
Oh!
It's him!
Oh, my God, our secret meetings.
I saw the boss's info was right.
You want to shoot a guy with glasses.
By the way, you can't use your gun while you're a scientist.
I can't use a gun!
What?
I see where you've made me taste bad.
I'm unarmed!
You can't hurt me!
Oh my god.
Are you sick?
Wow!
Wait, that sound effect.
But you're mine now.
Oh.
What sound effect?
You're like, fuck.
That's a...
I've heard that sound effect before, but from where?
Yeah, it's CinemaSins!
That's a sin!
What?
The bump is a cinema sin sound effect.
Oh, here he goes.
Yes.
Oh, there he goes.
Take very close attention.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
That's pretty cool.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh, I could just shoot him right now.
This is like...
Oh, he actually learned.
No, he's got to keep going.
He's got to keep going.
That's twirl for every, like five twirls for every shot.
This time I've got 12 shots.
Well, I only need one.
Okay.
Draw.
draw oh shit give me a sec i gotta change clothes yeah you
gotta change clothes you can't use your gun all right where
is he oh my god give me a sec i gotta get my gun too oh he
shot a rock is he stupid or something he is a little dumb
yeah there you go backing him up no where they're so mean i
don't even see him they're in the trees You can't attack on
him.
Are you kidding me?
Just leave him alone.
Oh my god.
How did he tank all of that?
Watch him reload.
The thrill.
The thrill of reloading a battle.
Watch him do it.
Oh.
His hat.
Don't do that to him.
Don't worry.
Watch me reload now.
There we go.
Let him use his bullets.
Let him use his bullets when he reloads.
Let him shoot you.
Don't worry.
I'm getting one.
HP and then I'll let him reload.
Look, see, I let him reload.
Oh, he got his hat too.
He got his hat.
Look, see, I'm so generous.
I know, it's so good.
Oh, my God.
He's fucking...
There you go.
Robin was yelling at you.
Wait, no.
Let him reload.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll let him shoot one more.
Oh, my God, there's a cat.
There's a Rallad dealer there.
Yeah.
A cat?
Is that what you just call it?
Is he reloading yet?
All right, there we go.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, that's six, seven, eight, nine, 10, 11.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
One, two, three.
It's so exhilarating.
Oh, my God.
I like how I just let him reload too.
I know.
Let him realize.
He's aura farming.
Damn it.
He found us.
Oh, it's the bee man!
Not the bees!
It was exhilarating.
I got that!
Okay, these bees are weak as shit.
Just fucking peace waters.
Oh shit.
Oh, it's very serious.
Ew.
Not the bees!
Just shoot him!
Why would you just stand there?
Like leave.
Yeah, why are you watching?
Oh my god.
There's a bee stupid or something.
Just sing him for a bye.
He's really stupid.
You were lucky.
Bro, he's parrying.
He's parrying the bees.
Snake!
No, snake!
Gabe, this is amazing.
What the fuck?
Damn.
Those parries were sick, though.
Yeah.
Oh, oh my god, wait, were you...
You didn't shoot him with your suppressor on, did you?
I have it off.
Oh, never mind.
You still have one.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, I can move.
Yeah, you're in the dark.
it was a cutscene no i was like this is a very long cutscene
welcome to the caves oh what do i have a flashlight that
would be crazy why would you need one okay just let your
eyes adjust okay give me a second oh there's oh there we go
i found water so uh this cave system is like kind of huge so
good luck wait what do you mean what do you mean wait oh i
found yeah oh you should eat them i'm gonna let go and then
yeah this looks like oh i have battery are you sure we don't
have why is there a battery what for the stuff that you're
like your you like your sonars and stuff that you haven't
been using okay wait does that mean the sonar would help me
guide me through this uh well you do have a map have a map
oh yeah You're getting the map tutorial right now.
I was like, oh, yeah.
There's like a ton of loot in here, though.
So you're going to want to, like, search thoroughly.
Wait, maybe if I...
Oh, I can see now.
Oh, wait.
I can see here.
Wait, my eyes adjusted.
No, that's just daylight.
There has to be stuff here.
Right?
Your oxygen.
Oh, no.
But there's a cave, though.
How do I get back up?
okay there you go there you go oh my god that was scary okay
i gotta eat again i gotta pee i'll be okay i was gonna call
someone anyway uh okay who do oh i should call my dad hey
dad i'm in the cave now snake are you okay snake major snake
oh my god dad was worried about me no that was a hell of a
He actually cares!
There's no way back up, though.
I see.
Well, anyway, it's good to hear you're not injured.
Slipping and falling may not have been part of the plan, but
getting into that cave was.
Proceed further into the cave.
The cave seems to be structured like a maze, but there's an
exit somewhere.
Find a way out of the cave and head for the aqueduct.
Oh, right.
But it might take me a while to get through this cave.
Are you hurt?
No.
Is it the enemy?
Did they set a trap for you?
It's a very scary cave.
It's dark in here.
I'm scared of the dark, Dad.
I should have brought a flashlight with me.
So what you're saying is that it's going to take you a while
because you don't have a flashlight.
Right.
Snake, if you don't have a flashlight, you should be looking
for a substitute.
A substitute?
American soldiers these days rely too much on ready-made
equipment.
Wait, what substitute?
What was that?
Nothing.
American soldiers rely too much on ready-made equipment.
equipment well not only that they can't seem to grasp that
one piece of equipment can have multiple functions what back
when i was in the sas we never had that problem we were
trained to use every piece of equipment wait so what
equipment can i use then you don't have a flashlight look
for something else americans am i right hey are you
listening to me yeah of course i am first take a look at
what you're carrying with you now don't you have anything
that can provide you with some light what what gives me
light i see you've captured an indian gavial the indian
gavial is a crocodile that originally lived in freshwater
regions in india and nepal bullets why are indian crocodiles
way out here oh man there's so much stockpile of dialogue
because i haven't talked to my new mom gavials are large
creatures adult males grow to over six meters in land no one
can replace my mom even if you use the tranquilizer gun i
tried the meat it was great well good for you but be careful
when capturing an indian gavel normally they're cowardly
creatures but the ones in the forest there are belligerent
apparently they attack humans what do you mean they weren't
the direct subject of any serious research but some think
they may have become violent as a side effect of the atomic
research that was oh we're scared we're scared of people now
Oh, what does Eva think?
Snake, are you alright?
Yeah, just barely.
What the hell were all those hornets?
Most likely that was the pain one of the Cobras.
I figured as much.
Are they tracking me?
I don't know.
The Cobras only take orders from the boss.
Not even Vulgan knows what they're really up to.
So I don't know anything about that.
She does care!
My mom cares!
She's sent in the pain to help me!
Yeah.
oh my god i knew it i knew mom didn't disown me i knew i was
part of i'm still part of the disciples it's a test it's a
test to see if i truly want to work for russia good i did
remember to tell you then if it's completely dark and you
need a light try you do love me i heard there's some
emergency torches stored somewhere in that cave torches got
it i knew it guys where are the torches Wait, there's
torches?
Oh, I can find torches.
Okay, that's good to know, actually.
Q-tips.
Oh, it does.
Okay, oh, cigar.
Okay, cigar, night vision goggles, and a torch.
Oh, my God, my eyes do a...
Oh, my God, that's actually crazy that your eyes actually do
adjust to it.
That's actually crazy.
That it does work like that.
Alright.
Just gotta...
Just gotta smoke a cigar real quick.
Okay, this way.
Is that...
What does the map say?
Okay, I'm going...
Further away from the objective.
You got this?
I'm gonna go get water.
Yeah, I got...
Apparently, I can use my cigar to light up the caves.
Wait, which I should equip my cigar then.
Do I have the cigar equipped?
where's the cigar wait a mouse trap what the fuck am i going
to do with a mouse trap oh wait i can capture them alive oh
there you go uh guess i don't need but no uh grab this
all right i can wear my crocodile hat again
Oh, what?
Nope.
I gotta light my cigar.
We cannot smoke while wearing a hat.
What?
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, look at all the rats.
Oh my god, I can sit on my little rat trap.
Wait, who's calling me?
Oh, no one's calling me.
Okay.
Where's my little rat trap?
All right.
Hello, little rats.
I got a special present for you.
whoop come on oh yes yummy delicious cheese come and grab it
oh yes cheese is so yummy
oh wait oh oh smoking kills that makes sense yay isn't it
yeah got a ride nice ow oh i don't oh my god oh my god i
don't poison oops Okay.
Okay, uh, serum.
Wait.
How do I... Okay, there we go.
Okay, wait.
Okay, now that's right.
Look at you go.
You won't regret this.
So I have to... I kill the snake real quick.
Yeah, you gotta kill them in the back.
Did you know smoking kills and it's not healthy for you,
apparently?
What?
Yeah, that's crazy.
Snakes should start vaping.
But also, it's also unhealthy.
What is this, 1984?
Come on.
Telling us to not smoke.
Yeah, wasn't it back then?
They had like ads for kids to start smoking or some shit?
Probably.
I remember back then they were like, don't worry kids, it's
okay.
Guys, smoking is not good, guys.
Don't smoke.
Yeah, we're kidding.
We're kidding.
We're kidding, guys.
Also vaping is also as addictive as smoking.
So like, because they have like bubble gum flavor.
Bubblegum?
Yeah, bubblegum flavie.
I don't think that's why people get addicted because of the
nicotine.
I mean, I think it's... I think because they invented
bubblegum flavie, they made it much more... Oh my god, is
that frog?
Nice.
That was a... What do I do with live animals?
So with, like, snakes, you can throw them at guards and
scare them.
I got a rat.
Oh, okay.
What do I do with a rat?
Ah, maybe the same thing.
They might be like, you a rat.
Wait, I can...
Okay, I'm gonna see if I can throw a rat, then.
Where's my live rat?
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I gotta go throw this rat.
Okay.
He's now a weapon.
You can also throw expired food and stuff or things that you
know are poisonous and if they eat it, they'll get sick.
she's like i just want to shoot them in the head yeah i just
want i was like make them get sick i'm not here for the long
term it's pretty immediate but you know is that safe yeah
that looks safe right yeah that seems safe that's totally
safe yeah i believe you It was safe.
I knew you wouldn't lie to me like all the other times.
You definitely didn't lie.
Oh, wait, that's a beetle.
That's a crab.
That's not a beetle.
Technically, crabs are the spotters of the oceans.
So I almost got it, right?
Did you know that?
I didn't lie to you when I told you to let your eyes adjust
to the darkness.
There has to be a quicker way to, like, swap to that map.
Oh, hey, look at all these spotters.
Oh, nice.
Okay, there's the torch.
You found it!
You found the torch!
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Start stabbing these crabs.
Yeah, there's the sea spotters of the ocean.
No.
Yeah, they are.
That's what crabs are.
Okay, I'm hungry.
else i know isn't it great to just kill them all and eat
them up wait i can eat them alive oh you could yeah wait
okay wait is there any difference between eating them alive
or eating them like not alive i mean he eats them raw so
what do you think like regardless yeah like i'm just saying
like is there any health benefits to eating them while
they're still alive and you know maybe they're juicier yeah
because like oh they don't spoil when alive oh that's smart
actually that's actually pretty smart is that well you just
gotta eat your food before next week yeah and it's fresher
too yeah because like you know how they say like the fresher
the fresher the meat the juicier it is yeah that's why i
said it's probably juicy yeah So how fresh can you be unless
it's like a newborn?
That's the freshest.
Oh, that's, that's why people eat veal, like baby deers, or
no, baby cows.
Yeah.
Yeah, eat them when they're babies because the meat is more
tender.
That's the freshest.
Wait, how, what do babies taste like?
You know how people always say talk about human meat?
Oh.
And then, like, human meat, people, like, because, you know,
because, like, I don't know.
You ever been curious?
Have you ever, like, read articles?
I mean, like, people ask cannibals, like, oh, what does
human meat taste?
like and stuff and then like a pork or something they it's
like more like grainy apparently because like the meat the
meat is more tough you know it's not as soft uh so it's
apparently like more grainy so i'm like why don't you use
the torch why don't you use my eyes adjusted to the cave i
can't see anything your chat can't see anything i see
there's the sun there's Guys, for legal reasons, it's a
joke.
Don't eat babies.
You can eat baby animals, though.
That's what Ville is.
Ville is so good, though.
I'm not Ville.
Oh, NVG.
Yeah, you can do that here, too.
See, that's what the battery's for.
That's literally what I told you.
No, that's not.
I don't remember that.
That's not.
Oh, there's the frog.
No, didn't hear it.
Wait, why do they associate cannibalism with you?
What have you talked about?
Oh, because...
Nothing?
God, stop telling her!
What did you tell?
What did you talk about?
Wait.
Why are you talking about cannibalism with you?
Because there's like, I have a plan of like, eating certain
people, and, like, I have a list of people that I want to
eat and I've been like kind of planning this.
Wait, where am I on the list?
Well, that's why I didn't want people to bring it up.
I'm not even on the list?
You don't know where you're on the list.
Where am I?
Where am I on the list?
Oh my god, it leads me back here.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
The yellow dot.
I went everywhere.
The thing that says objective.
Oh my god, where am I?
Okay, but like, I'm like a chicken.
So like I should be on, like high on the list, right?
Well, okay, there's other people that are like more chicken
than you, I'm just saying.
I'm literally like a chocobo.
How is there, how are they more chicken than me?
A chocobo is like peak chicken.
Because they're bigger.
You are a crow.
Okay, no, that's croaky.
That's different.
Also like pigeons are so good.
I've never had pigeon before.
no they're really good they're not crows but they're they're
they're sort of like crows yeah they're tasty wait can you
eat chocobo in like in final fantasy i feel like you should
be allowed to is it like is it like how in pokemon there's
like the illegal like no you can you can you can eat pokemon
they just don't show they they like you can eat magic carb
technically but like It's apparently not as good because
the...
I know, but there's like the illegal slow-poke tail trading,
you know?
You know, so is it kind of similar where some people eat
chocobos, but it's like...
I feel like it's like exotic dining, so you have to like go
to like...
You have to like go to those illegal restaurants for it.
Like, like the very rich, only the very rich can access.
Like if you have the money, you can like be allowed in those
restaurants.
like it's like eating a pet like it's just i mean i guess
some people you can eat you know that's what wild animals
are yeah or they could be like you know how the they had the
milk tank form and so what do they do with the milk tanks
when they're too old i mean or they don't yeah you know i i
get it yeah probably probably and where are you i don't oh
i'm back in the beginning i'm so lost in the second game
okay i'm gonna go like the torch i'm gonna say you know
there's this really cool thing called the torch okay where
the is the torch oh it's like our tier list remember we did
that tier list shit oh yeah yeah yeah i don't remember where
we put anything on that tier list i remember like mushroom
we're like yeah it's under weapon right is it in your weapon
oh there it is yeah it's right there uh what do i not need
okay we might not need this i can put
All right, there we go.
Now I can see.
Now you can see.
Barely.
Better than before.
Okay, it's this way.
There has to be like a quick section to just...
A quick section.
There's like something over here.
You see that?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I have a compass.
I forgot about that.
Oh, no, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
You're hungry again.
I'm hungry.
I'm going to eat the Russian ration.
How much does that give me?
That's so great.
Oh, it's not great.
I'm surprised.
Those are nasty.
They're gross.
What happens if I eat this?
Am I going to get high?
Try it and then...
Wait.
Oh, you're arguing.
Pretty tasty.
Oh, my battery charged.
Yeah.
Wait.
What?
Oh, because of radiation.
Let's go.
yeah it's all right you should call paramedic about it oh i
should something to say yeah okay i won't get cancer or
anything right uh well you literally were right next to like
a nuclear bombs yeah it's already too late for me yeah it's
way too late it's quite vicious and carries a potent
neurotoxin in its fangs be careful if it bites you go into
survival viewer immediately already did that he bit me and
then i shanked him that's right he was in the wrong
neighborhood then you'll just have to try it yourself and
see i didn't say anything but you were going to ask weren't
you about the taste maybe i'll talk to you later snake yeah
i did i caught a crab
swamps it's not poisonous but it might hurt a little if it
attacks you with its pinchers i can't attack me i have a
bigger knife it pinches oh why do you say must because it's
a crab it is and crabs are good to eat yeah you don't like
crab oh my god freak why not why how can you
a crab did she eat yeah purple and yellow what the what what
what crab they smell like cat pee apparently did you know if
a cat poops or pees in front of you he trusts you oh my cats
do that every day so yeah because like and if they look at
you too oh while they're doing it yeah they're like okay
because they're hoping you'll defend them because they're
like the most defenseless It's similar with dogs when they
look at you and they're like defend me.
I'm in I'm a vulnerable moment Yeah, I took my dog.
I told my chabas I took my dog to a Nature park and a hawk
started circling him Yeah, so we're not going back there.
We're My god I literally saw a shadow of a hawk.
I was like, oh, there's a hawk and then flew back and like
flew back to us and they started circling us like dog while
he was pooping.
Oh my god.
Yeah, but like dad looked at me in the eye while he was
pooping, while the hawk was circling him.
It's like, you better deal with this hawk.
He's like, take it down.
That's scary.
The carbonyl groups in the oxy-luciferin are initially in an
electrical excited state.
When they return to their base state, they give off...
Science.
Oh, there's mushroom tab.
Yeah.
not really oh i ate one and it recharged yeah huh i thought
a mushroom that glows that right was bound to charge up my
batteries if i ate it and i was right it's theory that's
just a game theory
snake can you excuse me for a second sure did you just hear
that sometimes snake does things that really confuse her
what do you think it means maybe it's all in his mind oh no
i think i'm crazy they think you're stupid they think i need
meds should we let him keep believing it oh no it recharges
your batteries i swear i saw it we all saw it we all saw it
we all saw it guys i'm not crazy where are you at I don't
know anymore.
Oh, I'm back here.
Okay, okay, I haven't gone this way.
This is the one area I haven't gone yet.
All right.
Oh, that's a different dead guy.
No, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, this is a new dead guy.
Oh, I got bug juice.
Bug juice.
So many people die in this cave.
Oh, my God.
The one area I didn't fucking go was the right area.
You mean...
Okay, I knew there was an easier way to look at the map.
sometimes you just need a little hand holding i knew it all
right no one will suspect oh wait look at all these oh my
god there's a snake oh wait there's a bat wait okay wait i
gotta start yeah the bats will like attack you so you know
oh they will they kind of yeah they're annoying why don't
you just knife it wait what are you trying to shoot we'll
shoot the bat
bat why would you I don't know I just thought could fuck you
shoot the bats you know why would you think that I thought
it would work you're getting the bats get the bats oh my god
you're biting me yeah just keep dodging dodging my fucking
hits they're smart well turn around they're behind you Okay,
there you go.
It's alright.
I have so many bats now.
Oh my god.
I know you have so many bats.
I'm all from...
Oh, you're just gonna eat it.
Okay.
What is this?
Oh no.
It's bats.
It's all bats.
All bats.
What's that?
Yeah.
It was AK-47 ammo.
Wait, was that a passageway?
Back there?
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait.
Before you go in there?
Yeah.
Was there a passage to your...
Wait, look at the map.
Oh, let me look at the map for some reason.
Oh, maybe I have to be out of here.
Oh, hey.
Smoke G.
Oh, see?
It pays to explore.
Just kidding.
I think I didn't see anything.
You're good.
Alright, nice.
Alright, off we go.
Uh-oh.
See, it looks like it, but it's not.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Oh, cutscene time.
Yeah!
Time for...
This is my mom.
It's not your mom.
Oh, it's the bees.
It's one of our friends.
We're role playing.
I'm a crocodile.
We do our little role play session.
Have fun with your first boss.
We are the sons of the boss.
Oh, shit.
It gave me.
Oh my god, he's like, oh my god.
That's his persona.
He's literally dressed as a bee too.
I know.
That's literally his persona.
I wonder what Snake's name would be if he joined the Cobra
unit.
He'd be like the baby.
The baby.
Yeah, the baby.
Wait, oh shit.
Oh my god, wait, what is he throwing?
What is he throwing?
Is he throwing bees?
So yeah, you're gonna want to, like, dive to avoid the bees.
Oh, that, okay.
Yeah, you're gonna want to, like, swim to avoid them from
attacking you.
Wee!
Then you can go up and you're gonna shoot them.
Oh, I can.
Alright.
I'm not getting a little shot.
Is he protecting himself with that?
Yeah, he is.
Oh, okay.
What the fuck did he do?
It's like a sense that draws the bees.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Tommy gun!
Yeah, little does he know.
Oh, dang, you missed your...
No, no, I'm not.
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, Tommy gun.
Tommy gun.
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
That's illegal.
Right.
That's it.
Tommy gun.
I literally warned you.
I said so.
I said that would happen.
I didn't think you would actually fucking...
What?
Do the...
Are the bees packed?
Like, what the fuck?
How do the bees have bullets?
They're like...
They're like stinging bees.
They're like crazy bees.
Yeah, but the fucking bees are carrying fucking Tommy guns.
That ain't normal.
How is it not normal?
Alright, swim fast.
I might need food soon, though.
They're bullet bees.
That's right.
Where am I?
Cool, it's gonna be me.
I need food.
Oh, my God.
We need food stack.
I guess we have a lot of vampire bats.
you have time to eat the vampire yeah yeah pause pause i
gotta eat pause oh wait can't throw a okay oh i can't throw
a rat at it no i wouldn't i think it only yeah okay i should
actually use my ak i was like maybe i'll just headshot him
but i feel like that's taking a while all right there you go
i wish my ak there you go yeah this is all the bullets i
haven't used
eat while swimming you're gonna get cramps no not the cramps
oh there you go okay yeah that was a lot faster oh my god
that was so fast
oh shit
oh is that where the bees are coming from is this head Oh,
that's where the B's are!
Oh, okay.
Oh, my God.
That's the super B.
Oh, his body is the hive.
Phase two.
Oh, that is disgusting.
That is fucking...
That's actually disgusting.
Eat this.
Grenade!
Yeah, he starts throwing grenades.
Yeah.
there we go yeah oh nice nice oh that does good damage yeah
yeah that's good they're carrying the grenade oh my god oh
my god the bees the bees are the bomb the bees are the bomb
they're the bomb okay hello I'm right here can you oh oh
okay never mind never mind oh they're carrying the grenades
okay okay okay I'm swimming I'm swimming I'm swimming as
fast as I can He's doing the Tommy gun thing too.
What do the bees not have?
That's so OP.
Nice.
Bang.
Wonderful.
All right, now I got E.
You could, like, grenade the bees off of him, but...
Oh, that works?
Yeah, it does work.
It does.
Okay.
See, I see I have...
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, geez.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh, I think you threw it over.
Yeah, I think I heard a bunch of things die.
Oh, where am I?
He's like, where did he go?
Where did I go?
There you go.
Oh, that's easy.
Yeah, I barely killed a lot of fish.
Yeah, that's good.
Free food.
Yeah, I got replenished all the food.
This is a good farming area, honestly.
Oh, no.
What about the pain?
the pain
yeah yeah that's like so normal this oh my god the poor guy
the way he just said he just floats up so he just floats up
yay the pain i wonder if all the other things are behind you
then the um other fish unless they despawn i don't know yeah
it should be floating up you know no they sink i think right
no no the food floated up oh did it yeah yeah the pain the
pain refuses to elaborate guys i mean does he need to
elaborate it's the pain guys it's the pain It's a ping.
Oh, the can sink.
See, I told you.
I don't see any.
No.
I threw it on this side.
I don't see any cans.
Yeah, it was definitely on this side.
It's fine.
All right.
Let's see.
I met AK with strong.
Do you want to get a shotgun?
There's a shotgun?
Sure, yeah.
Yeah, but it's back in the caves.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Like, what?
Like, backpack in the caves?
Yeah, back in the caves.
Are you okay?
Wait, there's a hole here.
Yeah.
Is it in this hole?
What is in the hole?
What's in the hole?
Nothing.
Okay, you could have said that before I fucking went in the
hole.
Well, I wanted you to satiate your curiosity.
Yeah, but now I'll never explore again.
Because I know it's just a lie.
Oh, what's there?
There's something in there.
I think that's the 8.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, that's important.
Is there something on that side?
You see that side on the left?
The little, like, the thing that looks like Florida?
Yeah.
Penis?
Okay, there's nothing.
You said it, not me?
What?
That's the peepee of America.
I guess so, yeah.
That's what everyone knows.
That's what they say.
Oh, I'm eating the fish.
Oh, yeah.
We get it.
Wow, you get a lot of videos today.
That's crazy.
Oh, are they, like, rare?
they're not like super common oh oh my god it's so also
terrible to watch they're also like kind of right the way he
goes in like a real dog he doesn't even finish it oh my
snake come on bro that's a waste of perfectly good food if
you're gonna eat it raw you might as well commit to it bro i
know there was oh all the ammo stuff he's button too that's
i'm grabbing my torch i was gonna say i can't see anything
you too wait is it all the way back i don't remember where
it is honestly i don't remember anything in the caves it's
so confusing in there yeah that's what i'm saying chat will
have to help you all right chat where's the shotgun i need
to pee too i'll be right back okay she's
peeing she's using the gamer chair right now she's using it
hello Hi guys!
Hello!
Uh, entertain you?
Uh...
Brrr...
Brrr!
Did you get the good burger?
Yeah, I did!
It was pretty good.
And I just finished my fries.
Shotgun is back and to the right through a tunnel, I
believe.
Does anyone want to agree with that?
All in favor say aye.
Don't tell Doki I use this Membo Supa on you.
Oh, well, oh.
All right, I'm back.
Hello.
All right.
So what the chat say was where the shotgun is.
Oh, they said it was back through a tunnel.
Oh, that is so helpful.
Like, with how many tunnels are in here?
Yeah, yeah, okay.
All right, which tunnel?
Which tunnel?
I feel like I went through all these tunnels.
Did you go through that really long one on the right?
Which really long one?
Yeah.
I went through all of these.
Which tunnel could it be?
That's that one.
What, the right side?
The far right?
I guess so.
That one?
I don't know.
The tunnels.
What do the tunnels say?
The one with the dead end.
They're all with...
Oh, that one?
Wow.
Who's right?
It's right.
The one with the shotgun in it.
one the long skinny guy on the on the far right it
could be anywhere it's right over next area what the i have
to go back underwear turn around to enter the hall before
the pain fight oh oh it'll respawn oh what respawn like oh
my god the goddamn bats get out get out i told you they suck
i told you get out it's okay i timed it this time Oh my god,
my food is full.
Kill him.
Alright.
Okay.
And then...
Yeah?
Wait, look at the map.
Wait, I think I found it.
It's here.
Oh.
Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're nice.
We found a shotgun.
Let's go.
Yeah, shoddy.
I knew it.
Alright, now we go back.
Nice.
And now I'm a little lost.
Is there anything back there?
there though is there an entrance over there that's what i'm
saying oh there it is there it is yeah
so where am i on the list wait you didn't tell me where am i
on the catabolism list like am i i'm edible obviously you're
not top five i'll tell you that not top five okay who's okay
who's who's number one then number one yeah is is kiara
because she is literally a chicken i'm a fucking chocobo
it's a bigger chicken you're not a chocobo you're not a
chocobo you're are practically one of the dragoons
practically looks like a chocobo how am i not a chocobo it's
a bigger chicken you could be higher if you are if you are
in tomato form how okay okay but like if you if you say it
like that then like when you combine all the dokees and the
dokevers i should be top five i'm don't i don't make the
list okay you literally
you're gonna have to talk to my wait okay wait where am i
ranked then i can't disclose that information well but you
can tell me who's rank one but not where i'm yeah because
that's public
knowledge that's crazy that's like why do you want to be
cannibalized so much is this like a fetish of yours like no
i'm just i just like to be number one i just like to win no
matter no matter circumstances it's all about winning it's
okay okay well that's why i also don't want to give you the
satisfaction of of it yeah but that makes you bias you know
i'm rank one in terms of eatability but you just won't give
it to me because of bias it's not it's it's it's just
science i'm sorry
oh god oh it's a cabs flying guys
wait you're right kiara's a fucking phoenix she's not even a
chicken she's a chicken and everybody knows it she needs to
stop it's it's like her our fans are the chickens that's
different and she's like oh nice i got she's literally
chimpkin wait does her restaurant like mean she's she's like
selling like her fans as me that's a good question because
like she runs what is it called kfp right so she runs a
restaurant so it's like but but what is the meat made of
don't question it that's the right that's that's like the
biggest so like rule it's like the rules of fight club you
know you don't mention where the meat comes from yeah so
like if she has like a job like if she opens like job
openings at the
you know where you're going you know where you're going you
either serve the meat or you are the meat oh you should run
over wait there's like a bunch of stuff in that little cave
area yeah
okay oh okay okay man
You have plenty of food.
It's your vibe.
Works every time, guys.
You fell for it yourself, so now you bring the pain to me.
Yeah, the pain.
All right, there's still one more.
Let me back up real quick.
Oh, my God.
It's also stuff I don't even need.
Oh, okay, never mind.
I need that.
Yeah, see?
I help.
I help, I help.
little rats right there I think if I get more I'm like it's
just gonna expire oh you think so you're not gonna finish it
today I'm pretty sure I have so much there's no way like
there's no way I'll eat I'll finish all yeah but you can
throw it at people and make them sick it's pretty funny and
then watch people throw up all right we'll see how okay you
know I'm curious we'll see how it goes.
Oh my God, it's all the way back.
I'm like, there's only one way and I'm still lost in this
cave.
Alright, this way.
Here I'll go.
Is this the right way?
That has to be.
Where else will we go?
Yeah, see?
Oh, wait.
It recharges my battery.
He's like, I'll grab that.
Don't fall.
Why?
You said... Are you lying about fall damage?
I would never...
Are you lying about fall damage?
Why do you not want me to fall, then?
See?
Oh, because look how deep it is you fall to the abyss yeah
but then i can tank it if there's no fall damage right
unless someone was lying what if it's never ending what if
it's never ending there's no such thing it always ends no
look see this way yay i'm back out in russia yay the russian
swamps okay so what's really cool about this part is if you
have the croc hat and crocsuit you can Oh, wait, really?
Oh, because they don't see.
Yeah, they just see a croc.
Oh, nice.
Wait, it's actually paid a win.
Wait, can I just walk upright?
Will they know if I walk upright?
Probably.
Oh, okay, so I just have to swim.
Oh, see, like, a crocodile.
I was going to say, is this suspicious if I start walking
upright, you know?
Why would it be suspicious?
It would be like, this crocodile is walking up.
on two lakes today it's probably because of the radiation
they're right i mean we did drop a nuclear bomb here earlier
today so maybe it's just maybe there's one of the spooky
mutated crocs you know yeah evolution is happening before
our very eyes yeah oh oh oh oh oh yeah i hope it's just one
way i'm not missing anything right there's no there's two
there's two areas to go too.
Alright.
Oh.
So once you're about here, you're like pretty...
Yeah.
Yeah, you're good.
Yeah, I'm good.
So now you pick...
You pick an area.
Oh, I can pick left or right?
Yeah.
I'll pick left.
Wait, actually...
Okay.
I'll pick left.
So right is the objective.
So left there might be something fun here.
Yeah, yeah.
There's always something fun.
Yeah.
It's battle gear.
Okay.
Never not.
What?
Okay, okay.
Calm down.
Oh, wait.
I can shoot him.
Yeah, you can just shoot that guy.
I'm just a crocodile.
Who's that guy?
Just a crack.
Oh, wait.
Your suppressor?
Oh.
Yeah, there you go.
Who's that?
I guess he heard him die anyway, so...
Oh, so sad.
Yeah.
Because I can do this.
So sad.
Oh, there he goes.
Kill him.
All right.
I'm just gonna...
Kill him.
Oh.
It's okay.
You can...
How many more bullets can you take?
Many.
Apparently.
Maybe shoot his head.
Oh, there you go.
I got the head.
It's just that.
easy maybe amber it's just that easy okay how many shots did
it take you huh what are you talking about yeah how many
shots did it take for you to kill him oh i don't kill
someone look at them oh you do a pat oh like a pussy what
like a pussy enjoy your river enjoy it wait what does that
mean
Wait, wait, man, what do you mean by that?
Man, what do you mean by that?
Am I not supposed to shoot them?
Man, those are some crucial information.
Go into where that light is, yeah, yeah.
No, don't worry, don't get, she's trolling.
I don't know, I feel like she's not trolling, guys.
I...
i don't know there's also poisonous spiders around here
sorry i can tank it okay that's what i thought yeah oh
what's this oh wait that's better than a pistol it's not
it's not it doesn't have a trank though or not a trank i
mean that's all right as long as i'm far away right of
Russia.
What the fuck?
How is this a sniper?
Oh, wait.
How is this a sniper rifle?
Oh, switch view.
Okay, there.
Okay.
No, no, that's a sniper rifle.
All right.
Guys, I had to deploy the information, but she doesn't know.
No, no, no, no.
No, no.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean by the river?
You're in the river literally right now.
Yeah, but there's clearly there's something going on
regarding me killing people and the river so there's a cool
thing in this next scene in the next area that if you shoot
the old man you can totally avoid his his fight but i don't
recommend that because his fight is really cool wait which
old man you remember the guy the old man with his eyes
bugging out yeah yeah yeah so i could kill him all right i'm
gonna go kill him but i'm gonna go kill him i don't for some
reason I'm not leaving that statement for some reason no it
really is it actually is you could save and then try it yeah
because it's like I mean you probably could do it one shot
but the timing is kind of no I think you could do it oh my
gosh pissy pants what
huh well
Oh, oh, it's the scientist.
You remember him?
Of course.
He's the guy whose wife you hate.
Oh, there's the...
I just think she's ugly and it's funny.
Yeah.
Really now?
How many times must I tell you?
Oh.
Oh!
But what?
What does she do?
He just does that.
Oh my god, he hates women.
each time you resist your lover will suffer the consequences
is that clear oh yeah his mistress yeah oh
shit bro she's strong oh oh oh oh in the pool oh at least
she okay At least she was, okay?
At least she was.
He improved the outfit.
Oh yeah, his future boyfriend.
You see, he changed his guns and everything.
Yeah, it's not graved anymore.
But his older guns were cooler.
It's not about the style.
No.
Oh, is it Russian roulette?
Yeah, baby.
if they're in russia is it still called russian roulette or
just a roulette
that's like french fries if you're in homeland roulette oh
true i'm going to pull the triggers he has three guns are
you ready
and he can juggle he is a man of so many oh my god he's so
talented
Three.
Four.
Five.
Oh, that's all.
You scared.
Oh, poor man.
You get to, oh my god, the steam too.
They added the steam effect.
That's like crazy.
You had to do asking it.
He looks like a sad puppy.
Oh my god.
Go change his pants.
And his mistress saw him be a little bitch too.
Oh wait no, his mistress passed out.
It's fine.
He's like, mommy, my gun.
Mommy, my gun.
Mommy.
Mommy, mommy, please.
Mommy, my gun.
Mommy, I did well though, did not.
She took it apart too.
Oh, man.
It's like that.
Go to your room.
Nice.
The pain is dead.
The pain.
He exploded.
Oh, shit.
He may be a child, but he's definitely one of yours.
Bro, I'm pretty sure like Snake is like, in his 30s isn't he
like well chai i don't know chai men maybe a mental chai
like yeah mentally yeah i know 100 mentally you have no time
to lose you must eliminate him before the final test the
final test don't worry they'll be able to handle it oh there
he is the end
Wake up, old man.
Oh.
We can run on water?
What the fuck?
Do you think this started like Pokemon?
That's all they can say, the fear.
They say their names over and over again.
Normally, he's dead.
What?
but it'll wake up yeah he's dead right now he's just
sleeping and be all it wakes up for battle and when he does
it will be the end for the boy oh that's like it just shoot
his head off because he's just yeah right now you could if
you wanted to oh
that's why i can't join her team because she's already has a
full party you can entertain me until the rain stops oh cool
a Kuobara, Kuobara.
Wait, what does he mean by that?
Kuobara.
Mommy, I killed your six Pokemon.
Can I join your team now?
Yes, of course.
Is that what you meant?
Yeah, yeah.
The sorrow.
Is that you?
Oh, R1.
You missed it.
Oh, no!
Yeah, it's a Nuzlocke.
Yeah, it's, yeah.
All right, now you can kill him.
Wait, save first before you do it.
All right.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I have to keep forgetting if they call.
You gotta call Parametic, yeah.
It's been a while since I called.
Yeah, it's been a while.
Yeah.
Save, please.
I'll do a new data just in case.
Yeah, do a new one, yeah.
Have you seen 007 from...
Oh, Jason.
James Bond.
Nah, I don't like those movies.
Real spies are nothing like James Bond.
It's pure fantasy.
Yeah, not like me.
I'm real.
You're real.
And even though it's fiction, I can't help but comparing
myself to Bond.
He feels...
Is it because he's British?
The cars?
The guns?
Hey, Jar.
Wouldn't you like a gun shaped like a pen?
Look, what is a pen gonna do me in the jungle?
I'd look like a fool.
Exactly.
I ain't no fool.
He is practical.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Get a shot in on the enemy while they're distracted.
Okay, now you're being ridiculous.
We'll make you a snake-shaped gun that folds off.
Okay, that actually looks sick as fuck.
I like that.
I want a snake-shaped gun.
How would you?
How would you shoot it?
You like retract it.
Oh!
Yeah, so it's like a long-ass bazooka.
I like the hanky-panky.
Oh.
Snake doesn't have time for women.
I mean, what about this evil?
for us a lot so true so yeah that's not what i mean you you
can't let yourself get involved this is a game of spy versus
spy she's using you just as much as you're using her uh-huh
uh-huh you've got to grab the initiative and to do that you
have to get the upper hand in the relationship that's what a
spy is supposed to do the upper hand i don't think i'm cut
out for that mission
I really have some like when you're British you have to be a
fan now that you've got him started yeah it's like a British
requirement to get your passport hour after he gets off the
radio you have my sympathy it's too bad you can't enjoy such
a great movie though I guess I'm just one of who can't enjoy
spy flex all right okay now get his butt oh they're gonna
wheel him away no oh there he goes i told you you're oh my
god oh there you go i got it he's dead oh nice oh you got
him yeah I did it, guys.
You got him!
I did it.
Okay, now you should reload.
The shot to end the war, guys.
I did it.
Alright, we're here, yo.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, I did it.
The shot to end the war.
Alright, let Grandpa go to sleep now.
Grandpa can go to sleep now.
What if I couldn't...
Is it advised to do it stealthily?
No, never.
You never have to do any stealthily.
You're right.
Yeah, nothing related to the river too, apparently.
I don't know.
You're literally in the river right now.
All right.
I'll just use it.
He's trying to wheel away, so funny.
I'll let him wheel him away.
them do that yeah there's less people so true bye grandpa
bye-bye bye-bye see you next week whenever we see you see
you grandpa pee bye-bye all right oh my my belly my belly
ground my belly ground music hey this works all right here
we go bye grandpa Oh, oh, there you go.
Ah, his friend didn't even notice.
What a terrible friend.
I know, right?
I wouldn't notice either.
Maybe he wasn't a good friend.
Oh, there you go.
You're dead.
Nice.
That's how you do it.
Yep.
All right.
Up back.
All right, take all their stuff.
Yeah!
Free stuff!
I love me.
That was so mad.
This floor is so slippery, guys.
Yeah.
It's so slippery.
Um, smoke gee!
Smoke gee every day.
Smoke gee.
That word you won't say.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, that's lyric.
Ah, yes, the infamous Snoop Dogg lyric.
All right, I need more ammo.
Nice, it got more ammo.
Smoke G.
Smoke G every day.
Your G stands for grass.
Yeah.
Which, well, your ass is grass.
That's right, touch grass.
I'm going to smoke it.
Alright, I don't need any of this.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it was that?
Oh, yeah.
A smoke tree in my brain.
What was that?
Oh, I think that's the poisonous spider, yeah.
That was a poisonous spider.
Why'd you kill him?
What are you beat?
You said it was poisonous!
He could have poisoned some guys.
What could you have done?
You could throw it at the guys and poison them.
It's alright.
It's fine.
How do I even catch the spot?
I don't have a fucking trap.
You have a trank.
No, I... Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
They go to sleep.
I forgot.
I could... I could have made them go zzzz.
Alright.
There's some guys in here.
I don't see any.
They're definitely there.
They don't...
You don't want them here in your tummy.
Alright.
I gotta refill my tummy real quick.
Do I need to be full HP for the... Oh, shit!
Oh!
Oh, fuck.
I told you there were guys in there.
Okay, I did not realize they were right over here.
Yeah, I told you.
You were like, I don't see them.
That's your blind ass's fault.
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta apply treatment real quick.
Disinfect.
Not the sudden cursor.
Fadage.
I don't know what you are.
I know what you are.
Nope, nope.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Knife.
Where the fuck are you?
fuck bleeding they're not stick stick stick stick okay there
you go see we're five everything is fine i'll be fully do
you know i'm gonna eat this tarantula oh that's so great
there you see everything is fine oh there you go well i
wanted to where's my rat i want to throw the rat oh i think
they're already like they're already aggroed so it's not
gonna work oh it's not gonna Oh, what's the point?
Am I?
I don't know.
I've never done it when they're aggroed.
I hear shots, but where are they shooting from?
Oh, from here.
There's, like, guys all around upstairs.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Okay, that's- Well, they called in reinforcement.
Okay.
You should dive into them.
Like, you can roll into them.
If you wanted to.
Oh, my God.
Okay, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Yeah, see?
of sea oh it doesn't work um um oh there you go r2 oh my god
oh my god do i do this oh they're just bashing my head oh my
god okay so guys okay i am i doing it where am i where am i
there you go you're on the ground oh you were you were doing
it okay there you go there you go okay there you go yeah
yeah yeah there you go there you go there you go there you
go everything is fine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
some more guys up there oh oh what does happen Oh my god, I
shot his body.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta cure him.
Oh, I have brain.
Oh, I have a I have a it's okay It's okay.
It's brain damage real quick.
Give me a sec Just a little just a little brain damage.
That's fine You're so close.
I'm so healthy Tasty.
Oh, yeah, you're so close to doing this.
Yeah.
I don't think you can eat anything else.
Yeah, you're just gonna have to deal with it Oh my god,
please!
Get me out of here!
Why don't you shoot him?
I couldn't!
I have to reload!
Oh, reload!
Oh, he's still up there.
His aim just sucks.
Get his head!
How is he taking all of this?
Take his- get his head!
No, it's okay.
And then...
Wait, am I bleeding?
No, I'm fine.
They're just, like, really almost dead.
You do have, you know, like, health that you can, like, use.
Oh, yeah!
I forgot about that.
Okay, let me just shrink these guys real quick.
Okay, I gotta make sure they're dead dead.
Because I see, I see, you see them.
And you're recovering, too, right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Okay, they're dead dead.
There's that guy down there, too.
Yeah, there's this guy, though.
Alright, nice.
There we go.
Alright, there you go.
Now I can loot them.
I need more.
Come on.
Give me your stuff.
Hi.
Heal again.
Where's my med kit?
Uh.
You have like a life medicine.
Where is it?
It's not really like a med kit.
See that top one up right there?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, it's vodka.
Nice.
Oh.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Oh, I have to equip it.
I thought I had to equip it.
I think at this point, though, well, I guess they might
start coming back around, though.
I don't know.
It's up to you if you want to just let it regen or not.
No, let's just drink it.
How do I...
Okay, let's see.
Do you have anything I want?
What the fuck?
What am I doing?
What am I...
All right.
Time to loot.
How do I drink it?
Uh, it shows you.
Like, if you equip it, when you equip it, it tells you how
to use it.
Oh.
Beep.
It doesn't say.
I'm trying to see how to drink it.
No, like, you know, when you select it and you're, like,
thing.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, there you go.
All right.
I can wear my hat again.
Yeah.
I take my hat every time I drink.
Wow, that didn't give you a lot at all That's crazy Alright,
reload Don't have a lot of bullets left How do I get up
here?
Nope Wait, there's something up Yeah, how do I get up there?
It's a puzzle It's a puzzle?
Yeah Oh?
Oh no They're calling in reinforcements Not again Oh no Use
your AK.
Use your AK.
Oh, yeah, I should.
Oh, I did not.
It's okay.
I can re-equip it.
Where's my AK?
Right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we don't need...
Oh!
Oh, my God.
You took out the light even.
There's a food thing, right?
Like, right now, you too.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Grab that.
Very good.
We're good.
We're good to go.
Oh, there they are.
There they come.
What's wrong?
Do you think he's okay?
Oh, shit.
Reloading.
There you go.
He's dead.
Yeah.
All right.
We go.
Oh, wait.
What food thing?
This thing?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
And then we.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
TNT.
No, apparently it doesn't work in this game.
Oh, wait, the food one does.
The food does.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember food does.
All right, yeah, now they can starve.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay, that was a little close.
Oh, that's...
Yeah.
There you go.
All right.
Yeah!
Did you get him?
Did he go down?
Yeah, he's dead.
He's dead, dead.
Yeah, he's dead dead.
Yeah, blow it up.
Now they're going to be hungry when you come back through
here.
Oh.
It's okay.
Oh, don't worry.
He'll come back up.
Oh, there's like so much loot because of them.
Are they going to come up?
Come up the stairs.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Holy shit.
Glad.
All right.
There's no way there's more people.
The entire Russian military is going to be down the one.
I fucking got rid of the entire Russian military.
There's no way.
Man, please help us.
I'm here for the vibes, guys.
This is how she...
I'm not going to back see how she plays the game.
What do you mean?
Please help us.
Wait, what am I doing wrong?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What am I doing?
You're not doing any...
You're not...
You're playing the game exactly as you can.
What am I...
What am I doing wrong?
Nothing.
What am I...
I'm a little worried now.
No.
Oh, you literally, there's no wrong way to play this game.
Wait, oh, oops, ointment.
Oh, oh, I didn't realize there was an animation.
Oh, no.
It's a game.
All right, nice.
Oh, it was nothing.
A smoke G.
Smoke G every day.
Oh, wait, there's no...
You have no suppressor anymore.
Yeah, I do.
Oh, now you do.
Nice, nice.
I mean...
It's nice and quiet.
Wait, I know what to do.
I have a do you want to try and get that thing up there?
What is it a good thing?
I don't remember.
I think it's a I think it's a suppressor.
What kind of thing is it?
I don't remember.
All right.
I'll do this and then since they keep giving me smoke G.
Wait, what's a chaff grenade?
Oh, it jams.
Yeah, jams are comms.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, no.
I'm going to do a stun grenade.
All right.
Oh, no.
Yeah, there you go.
There it is.
What is it?
Or is it a camo?
I can't remember.
Look at that.
Oh, yeah.
It was a suppressor.
I knew it.
Oh, okay.
But it was for your other gun that you don't use.
All right, here we go.
What a hard puzzle.
I know, right?
I told you.
Oh, there's a camo in the other area.
Oh, where all the rats are.
Oh.
There's a lot of rats everywhere, though.
Yeah, it's...
All right.
It's fine.
Here I'll go.
I think, guys, she's only going to be using the croc, so,
you know.
I don't think she really cares.
Wait, what?
Was I supposed to be a scientist?
There's a lot of traps in this area, so be careful.
It's alright.
They can't get me if I'm crawling.
Right.
Can't get me.
Oh, hey, there's a magazine.
yeah dirty book whoa if you put it in if you put it in front
of them the guards like start they start uh dragooning oh
hungry time man gets hungry so fast he gets like he eats
like six meals a day or something he has he has the
metabolism of the greatest metabolism ever yeah he's like
truly is a boy oh he's a growing boy he's a growing boy oh
there's a rabbit Did you just activate something?
Oh.
There you go.
No hesitation.
Yay.
Oh, and I got a serum.
Oh, I got ramen noodles.
Yeah, they give you serum too.
They gave me ramen noodles.
Yeah, the rabbit made that.
Yeah.
Did you know rabbit noodles come from rabbits?
From rabbits in Russia?
Yeah, yeah.
Especially Russian rabbits too.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's where they, that's where they make all the
ramen.
That's why it starts with R.
It was made there.
He was, it was like a rogue rabbit that like was a brainiac
guy and he invented it.
Okay, see, I got through the traps.
Yeah.
All the traps you got.
This is my stealth.
Finally, stealth.
Finally, what the P4 one is.
Stealth.
Yeah.
Nobody can complain anymore except here.
Oh, oh.
I knew that was coming.
I chose not to warn you to make you learn your lesson, Doki
Bird.
With what lesson I didn't learn anything?
What lesson was I supposed to...
Wait, do I have to get the items again, or are they...
I think so, yeah.
No, the magazine's not.
The magazine's gone.
Yeah, maybe you don't.
Maybe you're good.
Does he drop ramen noodles again?
Uh, no more ramen noodles.
I don't think he ever dropped the ramen noodles.
No, but I found ramen noodles there.
You should roll into those.
Oh, I'm hungry again.
You want some rabbit.
Yeah, I see the noodles are still there.
Pretty tasty.
Oh yeah, they're still there.
Okay, good.
They were self-passed gravity.
You're right.
I do have to grab the noodles to get wait that where did the
book go weird oh my god okay it's fine that was easy yeah
yeah yeah it's fine oh i got a call you think that oh what
what what happened to my god what what he just he didn't oh
so i i okay i didn't pick up for like one second and then
he's like watch out right there you see it now i see it now
there it is the book i didn't hang up i just i pressed it
and then he fucking hanged up on me you can climb that tree
if you wanted to oh yeah i forgot about how do i climb again
no there's only certain trees you can climb oh yeah oh this
tree yeah but why should i I don't know if you want to get
the there's like a Kedotan up there.
Oh, okay.
So I don't need to do it.
Yeah, you don't have to.
Just letting you know if you want to in the future.
Ooh.
Okay, so where is that trap again?
Yeah, what if he butt dialed you, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
Clearly it was a butt dialer.
It's right there.
It's up ahead.
Keep looking.
There it is.
Right there.
Yeah, yeah.
And now I see the Shikikipal leaves.
Yeah.
Oh my god, that is such bait.
Oh, fuck, I shouldn't waste that.
Yeah, there's no guys here.
Okay, I guess whatever.
Wait, just go through it.
I can't go through that.
Yes, you can.
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Yeah, it just looked very... It's just a little...
Yeah, it looked very bumpy.
Oh my god, now I'm paranoid.
Why?
Now I'm paranoid.
What?
All you have to do is use your eyes.
Wait, what?
Where do I go here?
Oh.
Was that it?
This is where you came from?
Yeah, this is where I came from.
That was it.
Yeah.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Okay.
I have to go to the other side.
Alright, other side.
Oh my god, I can sink here.
I can tell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I've
had a feeling.
Okay, it should be fine here.
Okay, any suspicious grass?
Oh, there's one.
There's one there.
Yeah, you passed that one earlier.
Okay.
So I just had to go this way.
To the right, to the right.
Nope, turn around.
This way.
Oh, turn around.
Where are you going?
Oh, this way?
What?
Oh, up the hill?
Yeah, it's over that way, yeah.
what what do you mean how do we get up there
oh it is we found it check the map if you're confused oh
there you go because i yeah oh we found it guys we found it
yeah that's what i told you yay we went right okay you You
are so close to becoming a scientist.
Oh my god, I can be a scientist.
Yeah, soon.
How do I cross that?
Oh, there's a dog.
Okay, okay.
I learned.
Guys, I learned.
There you go.
Doggy is asleep now.
I figured it out.
Oh.
Yeah.
Now kill the rest.
Why is that so weird?
that the dog fell asleep i don't get that he's tired yeah i
know like dogs sit down all the time and lay yeah he's just
sleepy yeah he's just a sleepy guy why don't you kill him
why don't you kill him oh i can't see i need to like make
sure i can you can move your camo when you lay down your
camo's like 80.
Okay, there you go.
That's fine.
Like, you can shoot and lay down at the same time, you know
that, right?
I can?
Yes!
Oh.
Oops.
I didn't know that.
He can only shoot while standing up.
He's such a man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, there we go.
Yeah.
It's that easy.
See, now your camo's like 85, so.
All right, I gotta eat.
Oh, that's everything.
Oh, that's a good ass, good ass meal.
Wait, can I just cross under this or no?
No, you have to find a hole.
Oh, there's a hole.
That one you should have saved, though, because it doesn't
expire, but you know, whatever.
Oh, I think the dog's awake.
Wait, the dog can wake up?
Yes, because it's a drink!
I don't know.
I thought the dog would be that, oh, I'm tired.
I don't have to work no more.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
There we go.
Can I, like, carry him away?
Yeah.
Oh, there he is.
Is that the hole?
No, where's the hole?
Oh, the hole's on the other side.
my god i gotta go all the way over there yeah all right i
gotta figure out how to deal with this dog oh wait can i
trick him double trick him oh yeah if he wanted to but like
it only extends his time yeah yeah i need to extend it
anyway all right oh there's a hole yep where there's a hole
exactly
be all right let's see what you have oh my god we're gonna
become a scientist oh my god it's time we're gonna be a nerd
time to nerd out i'm ready to nerd out just in case don't
wait i can carry oh i can't carry him though no she's got
such a nice coat they feed him i know he is very healthy Oh,
shiny.
He is a very healthy dog.
I can't even kidnap him.
I know.
It's kind of sad.
You can't pet the dog.
Nine out of ten.
Kojima, I can't believe it.
Didn't think of it.
He thought of everything, but he didn't think of everything.
You feel like he would think of that.
Yeah, I know, right?
That's what everyone wants.
Everyone wants to pet the dog.
Let me open the door.
Knock, knock.
Oh.
You can knock, knock, and then hide, and then someone will
come out and you can oh okay that makes sense it's kind of
fun well i gotta train the dog again give me a sec you don't
have to no just to be safe you're about to go inside yeah
but what if the dog wakes up he has three z's yeah but i
don't trust he's sleeping he's sleeping one more one more
for the ride okay yeah yeah yeah all right and then oh yeah
he did fix that and and and MGS5, you can pet the dog.
Yeah, but for a remaster, you think they would like...
Oh.
No, they were like we're making it extremely faithful to
the...
Yeah, you gotta knock.
You gotta knock.
Let me knock.
I think you gotta knock on the door.
I don't think I can.
All I can do is just open.
I don't think I can knock the door.
You can knock the door.
can I actually knock the door you actually well there's a
hole on the other side you can go through there too what no
no like not towards the door like no where you were headed
wait can I CQC the door I'm gonna CQC the door CQC the door
I'm CQCing
wait my back your back on it yeah you can knock on the door
oh okay now I'll kill that guy.
Grab him.
Like, when he comes out, immediately grab him.
Oh, I have an idea.
Interrogate him.
Oh, I was going to snipe him, but interrogate him.
Wait, how do I grab again?
I don't remember.
There you go.
Grab him.
Oh, what?
I tried!
Oh.
Oh, I'm in.
I'm in.
What?
Oh, I have to cure.
Awkward.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
It's fine.
We're in.
We're in stealth.
Yeah, stealth.
Stealth.
You're at 85 index.
They won't be able to see you.
Oh, no.
They saw us.
you not anymore oh they'd still see me no they won't they
don't they don't your alerts going down yeah the alerts
going down maybe they do no the alerts going down the alerts
going down yeah they're stupid they think they see you but
they don't actually they're just like yeah yeah so stupid
look see you don't know knock yourself they have no idea
guys yeah yeah yeah they have no idea they have no idea
they're just shooting at anything because they're scared oh
wait i might see Nope.
Um, that guy might see you.
Who are they shooting at anyway?
Hey, how is the alert going down then?
Yeah, see, we're fine.
Just a croc with a gun.
Yeah, just a crocodile with a gun.
Look at that.
How would they know that it's you?
Like, how would they know that it's a human?
I would see that and I would think it's a crocodile.
There you go.
Easy peasy.
Yeah!
Look at that.
I love when the evasion gets faster.
Everything is fine.
I can stand up.
Oh.
You might want to kill that guy over there.
No.
You should have killed him.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
No, no, no.
They lost sight.
Yeah, but now more guys are going to start coming around.
Oh, no.
There we go.
Oh, he was loud, though.
Why can't I be so loud?
okay yeah kill that guy oh he's walking away i don't have to
kill him he gets to live no he'll come back he'll come back
so i should kill him wait i got an idea i got an idea what's
that what this is for the rat oh the rat you're so right
okay we're gonna throw that rat at him You're gonna throw
it.
And he's gonna be scared.
And then you'll kill him.
You can set him on fire.
You can set him on fire with a torch.
You have a torch!
What?
Oh my god, I do.
Throw the rat.
No, throw it.
Throw it now.
Throw it.
He caught my rat.
Uh oh, you might want to look away.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, I'm sorry.
That's it.
Oh, we're fine.
Oh!
Sorry, everybody.
Sorry, I tried.
Oh, there he is.
We did it.
Stealth!
I was like, where did my rat go?
then you're ready to go yay I stealthed guys I have a lot of
bodies around right wait that guy was only stun grenaded
he's gonna wake up true I forgot about that yeah can I burn
it burn him while he's stunned oh try try yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah try try I'm gonna stealth here alright there
you go yeah alright you lay on the ground and light them on
fire.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
You have to light it.
I don't light it.
What?
Oh.
Alright, light them on fire.
Wait.
Go on the ground.
I don't think you can when you're on the ground.
Oh, yeah.
Thanks, Jan.
Now you don't have to waste bullets.
Oh, my God, you're right!
You're right!
I just think you can see it and burn them alive!
We're not mean.
We're not evil people, are we?
No, no, no.
That's how you play the game.
Yeah, yeah, I'm learning new ways.
This guy's already dead.
My sweater, Rob, is tough.
We're just learning new ways to play the game, guys.
Yeah, there's also, yeah, over there, there's like a little
shed full of stuff right there, yeah.
It's not food.
Oh.
Oh, it's loot.
Oh, it's TNT.
We need that, actually.
Oh!
Assault rifle.
Hmm.
But who needs that when you have a torch?
That's so true.
Oh my god.
I can CQC now.
So inside this building is where you're going to dress up as
a doctor.
A scientist.
Oh, I've only found out about the torch strat earlier.
Sorry.
I should have remembered.
There is a hole over there or you can go through the door.
Wait, what's the difference between the hole and the door?
You go in a different way.
Yeah, but I'm just going to be putting on a costume.
CQC, closed quarters, cremations.
The best way.
I'm going to go see the door.
I should just dress up as a...
But you got to change first.
Yeah, I was going to say I had to dress up as a scientist
first.
Yeah.
All right.
Would it matter if I have my hat on?
Yeah, I think you got to take it off.
Oh, do you think they'll know if I have it on?
Can I?
Let's see.
Yeah, the hat stays on.
Oh, it's just another door.
It's to the right.
Yeah, over there.
Right there.
Let's try.
Hello, everyone.
I'm the crock doctor.
I'm your newest.
I'm your newest crock dog.
Someone said I should save first.
I think you're right.
You're right.
You got to call paramedic.
What?
Why would you do that?
Oh, she doesn't want to give me a fun fact.
Oh, she does after.
Oh, there you go.
Nope.
Never heard of it.
Or the Croc, Dr. Crocder.
Dr. Croc.
The Crocder.
Oh, yeah, that's the newest ride.
They're going to be making that epic universal oh that's
cool yeah cuz it's like what was it called the monster the
dark universe yeah dark universe it came from outer space
were a lot more intense but it wouldn't be referring to you
coming from outer space would it whoa just because she's a
woman why did he say that yeah oh that's good that's good be
careful of what's around you when you're in the water jungle
rivers makes me think of you being attacked by a fish man.
I appreciate the concern.
Oh, la la la.
It's like the water movie, the deep in the water movie.
The what?
What are the movie that Gil, Gil Merrill del Taro made where
it was like this water guy.
And then they fell in love.
Yeah, and then she like fucked a water monster.
Yeah, what was it?
I forgot.
Hello.
I'm Croctor, the doctor.
Croc, Charlotte.
Yeah, yeah, I bled right in!
Oh, that's me.
Yeah?
Hey, wait.
Oh.
What?
It didn't work, does it?
Okay, it's not too late.
You can take it off.
Oh, okay, okay.
If I...
Just take off the head.
I think he slashed me.
Oh, my God.
You...
That's right.
You heard a doctor!
You...
That's right!
Oh, I think it's too late.
I think it's too late.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you're out of the belt.
It's over.
How does they know?
All right, now I'll just take it off.
They're discriminating.
Just don't run into them because they get mad at you.
Oh, hey.
Hi.
so scary it's like you smell in you what if i put the hat on
oh and then i take it off take it off take it off you'll
never know yeah you'll never know yeah you'll never know
okay do you like my do you like my crocodile hat did you
like it all right it's this way you're just going around
you're trying to find sokolov he's oh the doctors will
recognize that you're not a guy and will yell because they
suck oh because they're like i'm i'm a doctor i recognize
every doctor in this yeah yeah they're real rats they're
real rats so i can that's the hole that you would have
crawled through oh yeah yeah do i go upstairs or downstairs
i guess upstairs just explore yeah you have basically free
rein actually there's a part of the game where you have
actual free rein and it's really like i'm a real doctor
which i am yeah you're a real doctor everybody knows that
yeah everybody knows that you're a doctor is a doctor no
you're not because that will get you caught what open it now
you use the bathroom
oh knock knock oh it's just like a way to hide yeah so one's
the women's bathroom and one she don't oh no oh the one's
the library okay is there a doctor in here yeah scary if
there is a doctor in here i'll i'll seek you see him you
can't you can't you can't just just you have to only exist
as as the doctor the doctor the other guys they suck what
happens if the doctor sees me then what do i do just don't
don't let them don't let them so it's like there's no
women's bathroom because there's no women.
I mean, they're not wrong.
What?
Is this nothing?
What the fuck is the point of going outside?
If you want to leave.
Okay.
So it's not the second floor.
It's the basement.
Second floor basement.
Oh, someone said bring you down a little.
Oh my gosh.
This laid into the stream.
Am I loud?
I'll bring you down a little.
Yeah, I was like, this laid into the stream?
Sorry, guys.
Alright.
Got it.
I brought the game up overall.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, maybe this way?
Oh, hey.
Free food.
Oh, nice.
My ramen noodles.
Yeah.
Delicious.
Is your doctor in the house?
Oh.
Oh, no doctors.
Oh, wait, nice.
It's my little...
silly mags.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's an adult mags.
Oh yeah, you should put one down and see what happens.
What happens if I, oh, how do I put it down?
Uh, you just, you'll equip it and then it'll tell you like
you just put it on the ground and then watch when a guy
walks up to it.
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
Yeah.
What if I jump down, will you think it's weird?
Um, yeah.
Hi.
He's angry.
He's so bad.
Why can't you take a man can't take a shortcut anymore?
I know, right?
You want a book?
I'm a real doctor.
I'm a doctor.
I'm a scientist.
What is he doing?
I'm a real doctor.
Oh, okay.
I will.
Wait, who's...
Wait, where's my book?
Okay.
You have to open it.
Oh, oh, I forgot you can't do it in this.
Oh, not when you're a doctor.
No, doctors don't read.
Yeah.
We don't know how we just perform surgery.
Why can't a doctor perform some parkour?
Why can't a doctor read?
Yeah.
Just want to do some parkour.
disgusting behavior oh where am i oh there's some there's
some good loot in there something that you'll you might want
well you don't you you might want to just be careful of that
guy oh sorry what do you think you're doing oh sorry my bad
my bad he's checking you out i tripped and failed sir i'm
just a clumsy i'm so clumsy oh my god It's me.
Get back to work.
Can I get that thing behind him?
There we go.
Oh, that's fun.
That sounds fun.
Yeah.
Oh, I can't use it now because I'm a doctor.
Just very casually leave.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh, there's a scientist in here.
What do I do?
uh run around him like just run through just go go go go go
go go go go go go and there's a bunch of scientists in the
other room just go book it run uh oh god just don't don't
let them see you just go he's just walking just go do i go
go down the hall to the left yeah go down there oh god i'm
so scared i'm so scared i'm scared i'm so scared here you go
there you go i did it one of my I love this cutscene.
It's so good.
I'm just skedaddle with me.
Because you're looking for Sokolov.
He's not here anymore.
Where'd he go?
Huh.
Put that thing away.
Spoil my drink.
I love Granon.
So, you're the intruder everyone's talking about.
It's me.
Ooh, damn.
typical capitalist dog no manners oh he's an alcoholic oh
yeah you'll see you'll find out why never heard of me and
you'll call yourself an agent what is he oh he has a Gundam
in the back Gundam
I am the foremost weapon scientist in the Soviet Union and
the head of the glorious Gronin design bureau this is the
order of Lenin doesn't say that's Lenin given along with the
title of hero of socialism to only the finest workers it was
awarded to me in recognition of my brilliant contributions
to society now you're all washed up buddy since the great
patriotic war i have created countless weapons in the
service of our great communist society it was thanks to me
that we were able to stamp out the nazis scum damn he did
that who created the basic design for the mobile ballistic
missile oh and fear has ss1c
SS1C.
Why are you drinking if you're so proud of all that?
I'm merely drowning in my sorrow.
Because of him.
I've got nothing to do but sit here.
Oh, they did that.
They did that.
You know that Japanese practice?
If they're like too old, they can't fire them.
So they just isolate them in the office.
They basically did that.
It's him you're looking for, isn't it?
Uh, yeah, I guess so.
Yeah, they were like...
I have been stripped of my authority.
My research has come to nothing.
Look.
His research.
Oh my god.
It is a very mobile nuclear missile system.
A bipedal tank.
Ah!
R1.
A bipedal tank.
That's crazy.
Doki.
R1.
I thought that was the name of the take.
I was like, oh, the R1 take.
No.
That is Metal Gear Rex.
The Metal Gear?
Is that the Metal Gear reference?
Yeah, the reference, yeah.
It's like the one piece.
Metal Gear.
Solid.
No, he's solid.
Well, not him, but you know.
Well, you see, I'm going to send these documents to my
friend in the United States.
Oh, what?
What?
This is why this is why this is why I'm playing Metal Gear
Solid.
The first one is important.
This is why you play the games in order, everybody.
Yes.
Sokolov's pathetic shagohan pales in comparison to my work.
going to do with a rocket engine on a tank about sokolov
tank does not need a rocket what does it need what nice
shoes yeah legs
snake is actually the dumbest guy he wants to put legs on a
tank.
Oh my okay.
What?
What if a tank can run?
That's why Metal Gear Rex is.
It's a tank with legs.
Oh my gosh.
What if a tank can run guys?
They should put legs on a...
They should put legs on a plane.
Oh yeah.
So when they dock, it's like a superhero pose.
Haven't you heard of the philosophers?
Okay.
Lord Dump here.
their immense legacy Volgin's father was in charge of the
philosopher's money laundering activities in the confusion
of the war they somehow ended up with their treasure and
Volgin inherited that treasure illegally we never need to
worry about the military budget the development costs at our
facility are all paid yeah I was gonna say I don't fuck you
to get the funds for this the weapons born here will be the
genes for creating an entirely new form you should add legs
on the helicopter in arms yeah the funding for my research
came out of that legacy came out of it now my money my men
all have been diverted to the shagohad project Shagohad.
Do you remember seeing that?
Sokolov is making the final preparations.
Which what part?
There's a lot of blueprints.
The Shagohad.
I'll explain after he's done with the lore.
Drinking myself into a stupor.
That's where they moved Sokolov.
Yes.
And the Shagohad is there too.
Of course.
Oh!
Oh, it's the thing that we saw when the...
20 helicopters we're carrying yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
remember i remember it's an impenetrable fortress i'm sure
it is and now i'm gonna penetrate it my chances oh yeah baby
yeah now i'm penetrable when i'm there you fool i want to
help you help me to thank you for your
What the fuck?
I wanted to thank you for complimenting me.
That's so crazy.
I will betray my country because you complimented my shoes.
Well, he's already kind of like upset at everything.
You should be able to use it to sneak into the base.
Head to the mountains.
entrance to the tunnel is located there take this tunnel
well a lottery card the winning numbers the win numbers are
five seven so remember this is the warehouse he went yeah oh
he went through before him yeah there should have been a
door inside of it yeah it kept going yeah oh i remember yeah
yeah that's where i did the my my parkour Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Beyond that door lies the vast jungle.
You can climb up into the mountains from the far end of the
jungle.
Go back to the warehouse.
That door.
That exact door.
All the guys in here are gonna be so hungry.
Oh, yeah, they're gonna be so starving because I destroyed
all their food.
It's like real Russia.
Yeah, they haven't been able to snack or anything.
He loves his country.
I cannot even imagine living anywhere else.
I wish to remain a hero of the great motherland.
I mean he's betraying his country though by helping an
American dog.
It is already dawn.
We must hurry.
Oh.
Remain here and nurse my troubles for a little longer.
Oh, look, there's the Gundam.
Why does he have a Gundam in his room?
It's from Zone of the Enders.
To capitalism.
Capitalism?
Bro, he has the Medal of Lenin.
He just hates Sokolov because everyone was listening.
like no we're not gonna follow your plan we're gonna go with
sokolov's plan so he's really salty about it bro you guys
he's so salty he went straight to capitalism yeah oh oh i
have an idea okay
okay you're definitely gonna get caught here okay so be
careful Now they'll never know.
Literally every single one going home.
We did it, guys.
We escaped.
It's dawn.
I haven't been... Oh, I've been here.
Oh, it was that door the entire time.
Yeah.
Oh, I have to use the back door.
That's this one, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, it's sunny now.
The sun is out.
Uh-oh.
Well, you cannot be a doctor anymore.
Yeah.
Ah, no fun.
Okay, wait.
I know.
No fun allowed.
Wait, I wanted to try...
What was the item?
The cigarette that you got.
Oh, there you go.
The cigarette.
Yeah.
What did I do with it?
You gotta be, like, really up on top of them, though.
Now, like, ready it.
Oh.
Did I...
Okay, he's...
Yeah.
You have a limited amount, also.
This is HQ.
Oh.
You can just leave.
Oh, not leave that way.
Why did you go inside?
Um...
Not smoking kills, guys.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, burn them.
They're not going to notice that.
Yeah.
Now I leave.
Oh.
Okay.
Now I leave.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this looks like Big Saru.
You're doing the real strat right now.
Okay, just keep going.
Just keep leaving.
There's people.
Go where you came from.
Yeah.
Are you going to use this?
I wouldn't use your suppressor.
Whoa!
Oh, no.
Wait, wait, what?
Can I stun the dog?
Yeah, you can stun anything.
Big Sado mentioned.
Why are you?
Don't waste it.
Wait, there's a lot of them.
Okay, okay, I didn't realize there's a lot of them.
Watch this.
Yeah, they're angry.
Okay, when you throw it, look away.
Okay, there you go.
It's like Counter-Strike.
Did it work?
What did I do?
I don't know.
I don't know what happened.
Oh, not disinfected yet.
Look away.
Oh, there you go.
Yeah.
Oh, there you go, yeah.
Oh.
All right.
Oh, so close.
I'll just kill this guy.
Yeah, I'll just kill that guy.
Yeah, just kill that guy.
Okay, now I'll kill him too.
Yeah, kill him too.
There we go.
Yeah.
The dog,
the dog.
It's okay.
The dog's fine.
Dog's fine, guys.
Don't worry.
Oh, shit.
Oh, where did that guy come from?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Fuck this.
Oh, there's multiple guys coming out.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
Oh, oh.
You can maybe use a...
Okay, yeah.
You use a what?
It's fine.
Use a what?
Nothing.
No, nothing.
Use a what?
No, no, use a what?
Mouse active.
I was gonna say like your AK, but so you don't waste these
bullets.
Yeah, but I got two hit shots.
Oh.
I'm so glad he didn't overreact.
I knew he was gonna wing.
I have to be sure.
I'm not.
Wait, I tell you, you can trick the dog.
You can trick the dog with a cigarette.
Yeah, yeah.
We have to test the theory out.
The theory was right.
Oh, you're hungry.
Oh, I am so hungry.
Hungry.
All right.
I eat the Kenyan mangrove crab.
Pretty tasty.
Yes.
ice all right i'll go back to the the warehouse yes i gotta
go back through the woods here we go oh my god not the
fucking trap woods too oh my god oh oh what's that is that
the fear oh my leg
What the fuck?
What am I looking at?
Fear.
Fucking Pokemon shit.
Oh my god.
Oh, he's a snake.
No, he's the fear.
The Brazilian wandering spider.
Oh shit.
No, we're in Russia.
How do you get a Brazilian?
Yeah.
Brazil mentioned.
Come to Brazil.
Oh.
Are they like genetically engineered or some shit?
Like how do they all have animals?
I don't like his arms.
Oh my god.
What?
That's the tongue?
Oh, no!
What the fuck?
It's the fear!
What is...
Okay, alright.
Yeah, you're gonna want to cure first, too.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I gotta cure...
Oh, I know I have...
Alright.
Yeah, I have poison.
It's serum time and then get the...
disordered bolts i assume it's a knife right okay yeah uh
disinfect and bleed oh oh oh yeah i don't have a oh oh oh oh
oh okay yep there you go we got it we got it all right um
i'm gonna grab this and this oh someone's calling you what
the fuck oh no no they're not I heard it.
Where is he?
I tell for his traps too.
Stupid fucking traps.
Oh my god, I see you.
Get out your ass out of here.
Yeah.
What the- There we fucking go.
What the- Nah.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay, this sniper barely does damage.
I'm not gonna lie.
Like, I might as...
You're already at, like, a quarter of the way, almost.
There we go.
Like, you're just standing at one spot.
Hey, he's got to come over!
Oh, here it comes.
Oh, what?
He said here it comes!
Oh, my God.
I couldn't see the fucking jungle is sending me music right
now.
Like...
You're burned.
Oh, my God.
All right, we'll see what the AK does.
I feel like...
Yeah.
Oh, there he is.
We're fine now.
Yeah, no, the AK does more.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I'm just there.
Yeah.
Oh.
What is he sending?
Oh, you might want to move.
Yeah, I was going to say, do I?
Yeah, I don't trust that area.
Yeah.
Where is fear?
He does run on the ground sometimes.
times too so watch out for traps watch out for traps oh wow
you just missed that one that's crazy yeah oh there he is
yeah gosh playing this game lethal is so easy are you
fucking kidding me okay all right okay okay let me grab this
fucking thing off of me Oh my god, I keep accidentally
suturing.
I don't know why.
I keep wanting to suture it.
And then I got a knife.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh my god, it's so fast.
So if you do it like non-lethal.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he has like combustion.
They all do it's just normal cobra unit things just But if
you do it if you do it least or non-lethal Yeah, um He'll
like, you know because it's his stamina he can replenish it
so he'll like go down on the ground and like eat animals and
stuff It's like so and then what do you mean by non-lethal
though?
Like do I so you have you has like a stamina bar just like
you do yeah so you can do it non-lethaly with draining their
stamina instead of oh and then he just gets tired and then
but they still explode and die like yeah you use the trank
gun oh oh okay and oh no no that trank gun is not it that I
know, that's why it's so easy If you do it lethal It's not
in, no, that No, I fuck, no, I do not fuck With a train gun
with the goddamn projectile Shit I don't think Vito
mentioned that you could non-lethal the bosses until now,
well I knew she wasn't going to So Yeah, no, and they were
right They were I'm saying Why did they give me a gun Why
did they give me a gun if I could just shoot them in the
face.
What's the point?
Okay, this is like full of people again, by the way.
Oh, yeah, I see you.
I didn't think they saw me.
Granini Gorky.
You think they're still there?
You think they'll just...
No, that's fine.
Okay, then I'll just show this.
Granini Gorky.
I'll just show this.
if you if you beat them non-lethally then you get like a
special camel so it's really just for the
challenge but i don't think that did anything you said
what's wrong oh all right how about this i'll do a
non-lethal thing here oh wait i got book oh really oh well
yeah you could try
down i'll go
Down I'll go.
Oh, see?
Oh, oh, oh.
All right.
Oh, no, there's a guy still down there.
Yeah, yeah, watch this.
Oh, you didn't look away.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
But it's chat, okay.
Chat, are you okay?
See, I got it.
Yippee!
Look at that.
Wow.
I told you I can do it.
I told you.
Immediately equips the grenade in.
And the torch.
Yes.
I bet the water in here is like, probably has like gas and
stuff in it.
It's probably disgusting.
Yes.
Get that out of the gate.
Oh, I think he's already dead.
Get him.
No, this guy.
Oh, no, he's still alive.
Never mind.
No, we're just got to line up.
Line it up correctly.
Yes.
This is so...
This is so messed up.
Non-lethal, she said.
I did it, guys.
It's as non-lethal as I could do.
I did it.
Yeah!
just want to watch the world bring telling you about the
torch was a good idea yeah I think there's like a thing over
here in the corner yeah a camel there it is oh oh there my
goggles whoa I can see in the dark now I think there's
people that right next to you the rat no there's a box oh
it's bandages oh see you need that okay now I got the book I
don't think there's a guy up there would you like to read
okay there's no guy up there then it's cqc oh we already
made it nice yeah so um you can leave obviously yeah but uh
just you can like actually leave you're not gonna go into it
like anything or okay but you're um there's a little bit of
time before you head into the fight with the end yeah which
i would recommend um doing next time because his fight is
kind of I actually I don't know you might be able to do it
but it's basically his fight is kind of RNG so oh yeah it
could take you two seconds or it could take you two hours
why why would his fight take two hours why not yet anyway
but you better It's faster lethal.
That's why I'm saying it might be okay, but it's just the
RNG aspect of it.
The Colonel won't have any qualms about killing him if he
thinks the CIA is closing in.
Eva, you can't let Sokolov out of your sight.
Sokolov's gonna die!
Oh no!
Grozny Grad.
That I should be able to get there from the mountains to the
north through an underground tunnel.
Granin told you?
Yeah, he even gave me the key to the warehouse.
Why?
Because he was drunk, I guess.
You've got to be kidding me.
No.
Snake, there's one problem with that route.
What problem?
The mountain entrance to the underground tunnel that leads
to the fortress is sealed.
You need a key to get in.
A key?
What about the key grant?
Yeah.
Didn't you give me a key?
What?
What the fuck does it open?
Like, what the fuck does a key do then?
It opens the tunnel.
On top of the mountains.
Meet me there.
top of the mountains got it top of the mountains baby yeah i
got it i've got to tell you yeah i heard that one of the
cobras is waiting for you in the jungle at the foot oh it's
the end he's a legendary sniper called the end yeah yeah
i've seen him before that ridiculously old guy right don't
underestimate him he's known as the father of modern sniping
oh you could try it if you want all right it's a really fun
fight all right let's try it and see how it goes Yeah, yeah.
I don't need no spotter either.
The entire forest is on his side.
The forest?
What does that even mean?
I'd hate to have it be the end for me.
Yeah, what does it mean?
The forest.
Alright, so should I equip the sniper or AK then?
Yes.
What do you mean by that?
Alright.
Probably the sniper.
But I would save before, like I would save in this right
thing right now.
No.
All right.
Ring, ring, ring.
Saving the game, Snake.
Yeah.
Snake, have you heard of It Came from Outer Space?
Oh, another space?
Wait, didn't?
Yeah.
She told me this movie.
Like the next four calls is just about this one movie.
She was really into it, okay?
He's really into the space movie.
The safety effects were quite realistic.
I've got all the real I can handle here in the jungle.
No.
Wait, was there even 3D?
Like...
With the images jumping out of the screen at you.
It makes for a nice escape from reality.
I have to admit it made my...
Wait, didn't this...
When was 3D invented?
Yeah, I was gonna say, it's...
Wouldn't that this movie be after the Cold War?
I was still in college, so probably about 10 years ago?
Guess I'm out of luck then.
Red and blue 3D?
You know, they're coming out with household versions of...
Oh, 1940s?
Oh!
Whoa!
I didn't know.
not know that.
Whoa.
I was gonna say, they exist around the Cold War?
You're kidding.
Someday they might make movies where you control the
characters yourself.
Oh man, I wonder when that'll happen.
Yeah, I wonder when that'll happen.
Probably call my dad real quick.
He's gonna tell you to fight the end.
Hey dad.
Are you proud of me?
Yeah, she said we'd meet up in the ruins at the top of the
mountains.
She also said she picked up the key to get into the tunnel
that leads to Groznygrad.
Good.
Hurry to the rendezvous with Eva.
Head for the mountains.
Proceed north through the woods.
There's an entrance to a mine shaft.
Oh, you just scared me.
But dad, aren't you proud of me?
I'm on it.
Do you not see what I did?
Yeah, time for the end.
There's no way.
that's crazy it's like back-to-back boss but i know this
part is kind of funny with it i was like did i was like i
literally just killed a boss you're gonna go through like
all like the last three basically and then you hit like a
point where you don't go through fights boss fights for a
while and then you do the final ones oh yeah it's gonna say
i thought they would like pace it because like you know no
there's like no she only has three I already killed all
three.
But yeah, I still have a lot of playtime left.
So I was like, I'm pretty confused about that.
Oh, I hear the bees.
The bees.
I'm lost.
You have a map.
Oh, is this it?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, there's people here?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, why would you think there weren't be?
I thought you said I'd go see the end.
Yeah, you will.
I just assume I'll see him here you gotta get up there oh my
god are you what the fuck where did he come from holy cow
okay I'm fucking running I'm booking it oh shoot there we go
I'm fucking booking it I'm fucking going straight to the end
you should reload while you're running Like, it's already
too late for me.
They already called everyone in.
Stealth is off, you know what, everybody?
Is this the right way?
Yeah, it is.
It is, it is.
There's no stealth anymore.
They already called the reinforcements.
They're over here.
Oh, CQC.
CQC him.
Yeah!
Alright.
Well, he's alive, but whatever.
Wait, where's his buddy?
There's his buddy.
Wait, what?
There you go.
I told you he was alive.
There we go.
CQC is not to kill unless you slit their throat.
Yeah, but he like, he, like, I thought he was still
sleeping.
Oh my God, how many people are in this area?
There's a lot of guys in this area.
Oh.
Oh my God.
And then he brings his pistol.
Game doko.
I thought you were playing with a mouse.
Okay, all right.
Oh my God.
Okay, I'm flipping back on the mouse.
I wanted to do seek.
I wanted to wait.
Let me cure myself.
I wanted to, oh no.
Oh no, it's in my head.
Brain damage.
Disinfected.
Bandage.
Bleeding.
All right, here we go.
And then I need to eat real quick.
I need to eat.
I got pranked.
That's so great.
Get pranked, bro.
All right.
Alright, now, now I can do my stealth thing.
You're what?
Now I can start stealthing.
Because I didn't realize there were a lot of people on this
hill.
Yeah, there's a lot of guys.
Alright, watch this.
Okay, now that he's dead.
Oh, I'm behind him.
Oh, my God.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me look at the map.
You should just keep going, I think.
Yeah, I'm already here.
Yeah, let it just go.
There we go, get me out of here.
Oh man, good times.
Yay!
So when does the stealth start?
Right now!
No, no, no, no, no, no, this is a boss fight.
We're not, we're not doing it for the boss fight.
Oh, uh, yeah, you can.
I love this speech.
It's so good.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he's in full camo.
Wait, who put that outfit on him?
Because he was not wearing that.
Yes, he was.
Was he?
Oh.
Yeah.
You can't shoot him.
He's got a bird.
Oh, shit.
He woke up.
When is the end?
Yeah.
Time to fight, baby.
Oh, God.
I hate that.
That shit.
I beg of you.
me the strength to take this final prey
let me linger in this world just a little longer so i
thought i would kill the end in the end not in the beginning
no why would you think that because his name is the end Oh
my god, he's God's chosen one.
Yeah, he's the power of God in anime.
God's favorite.
My sleep would have been eternal.
Oh.
Oh!
Do you hear me, Snake?
There's me.
I am the end.
He's so cool.
I am here to send you to your ultimate fate.
You can R1 again.
Oh, oh.
Oh, God, stop.
Not that.
He's a guard sniper.
I found that sniper you were talking about that's the end
he's a legend known as the father of sniping I've got
experience yeah urban and marine environments what about the
forest never I see well that forest is divided into three
areas a river um man is this the river is that sounds like
is that the river no is that is that just forget about that
is that the river that
this guy's over a hundred years old though so i should have
the advantage in terms of stamina
i've heard that his body is photo oh it's like quiet oh my
god is that like his dad is our dad to the forest too so in
other words her dad i don't think this guy has i think this
guy is like or maybe his grandpa children probably yeah he
was like great great grandfather yeah i mean they just those
swimmers still work right all right have fun i snipe him
right yeah you gotta go find him i mean he has to be up
there does it that's where i saw the cut scene i guess not
there's a snake there can i shoot the snake you can yeah you
can just shoot the snake
like what so uh one hint is like you'll you can see so those
yeah those are like where he'll snipe from those little
points oh so he's gonna be in one of those three spots wait
i'm in one of spots right now yeah but also um uh his his
thing will like his uh what's it called his gun will like
shine yeah you'll see it like it's shining i wonder if he's
in this area you might have moved to another area oh this is
what you mean by two seconds
yeah the scope will glint thank you guys thank you yeah
all right so i don't see him in any of those spots then you
can if you're confident you can go to another area
uh you'll know if he's oh i'll know okay okay okay okay yeah
i assume that he'll shoot me right yeah okay he's not in
this area so how do i to this area oh okay yeah just keep
going it's
so fun i i do not oh there you go wait that not that's him
what i did how did i not shoot him
okay well um i have several bullets on me now not yet
removed there you go Oh, he's tranquilizing me.
What?
Okay, okay, buddy.
Oh, that was cheap.
That was cheap.
Okay, okay, I...
Okay, okay, okay.
You might want to up your camo, like, for real.
Okay, yeah, no, I agree now.
I...
You might be right.
Okay, uh...
Which one is...
Okay, I think this one.
Naked Woodland apparently is the best.
Woodland.
Wait, how come I can't... Oh, I already using it, right?
Wait, why can't I use it?
Yeah, I think it's already on your face.
This is a no paint though.
Yeah, but you have stuff on your face.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I'm fucking stupid.
old man you
can also lay on the ground and snipe yeah i know i'm trying
to oh
no i'm getting out the hugger there he is yeah isn't that
lump him no there's no way is it no that's not it is that
not him right there what is that that looks like an item oh
yeah that is an item shot oh i shot that the lump looks like
him asleep
i'm not even hungry i'm oh wait i am hungry i was looking at
his food i was sorry all right i was looking at the top
stamina bar
all right there we go all right nice
can he move or no oh yeah he he will run Oh my god, are you
fucking...
Okay.
He moved.
Yeah, he definitely moved because he's not shooting at you
anymore.
That's my bad.
I did not mean to shoot that gun.
He's behind.
I see him.
Yeah, you see his glint.
You see it?
Yeah, yeah.
The shine.
Oh, nice, nice.
Where are you old man?
He's like right behind that tree.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
So, okay.
Yeah, he actually runs.
Okay, okay.
He's very limber for an old man.
He's so fast.
He's just fucking running.
Yeah, he books it.
Nice, nice.
I don't see him right now, so he ran this way.
Yeah, he took off.
He took off.
Yeah, that way.
Yeah, through there.
Yeah, he's very fucking nimble for an Yeah.
He goes.
Where the fuck did he go?
I told him he's fast.
Like that's way too fast.
No, he's really fast.
I'm gonna give you lots of ammo too.
Oh, oh, oh.
I think he's up top, like up in the middle.
Yeah, I see him.
Actually, I don't see him.
It looked like his bullet came from the right.
Oh, I see him.
You do?
Wait, yep.
There we go.
Like, there's no way he got that far.
Because he's not going into other areas right now.
You're getting lucky.
Where do you go?
He ran.
How did he even get up there?
How the fuck did he even get up there?
There's no way.
He had insta-transmission some shit.
Oh my...
Oh.
I don't know where that is, though.
Oh, I see him.
I saw a hint, yeah.
There we go.
Nice.
Wow.
What is this RNG?
Holy cow.
So good.
And then also, if you do stamina, or like if you do a
non-lethal with this with him he restores his health through
like the Sun so you have to get him really fast okay eat the
stuff that will expire yeah I mean the Kenyan crab pretty
tasty nice where is he now where'd he go if he stays in this
area is cheating oh shit Oh, he's back!
That's funny.
He fucking came back to the same area.
He fucking...
Get his ass!
Wait, what did he draw?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
He fucking went back to the same zone.
He was literally there and he came back.
What if he does it again?
Oh, I see it.
Ducky.
Where is he?
the end yeah if he stays in this area that's so messed up I
was chasing him everywhere the first time I beat him it was
super fast and I had good RNG the second time I was losing
him everywhere I see him I see Ducky yeah I mean he's not
here anymore unless he's right behind me he is right behind
me What's the right vibe?
No, no glints.
Yeah, I don't see anything.
I'm just gonna grab some food real quick.
Oh, I should just eat the...
I should just eat the toxic mushrooms.
They're not toxic.
The radioactive mushrooms.
Radioactive!
Oh, there's a frog too.
I think he moved.
I think he might have, yeah.
Yeah, he's not shooting me and I'm just in the open.
I swear to God he just needs one more hit I swear to God if
he's back in the same bush I swear to fucking God I'm gonna
stand on this area just to be sure what walk around just to
be sure because last time he was like up top right like here
yeah yeah all right yeah We got the action explorer now.
Alright, how do I...
Oh my gosh, what the fuck?
I'm already hungry again?
Holy fuck.
Oh, I was just running around.
I already got hungry.
Yeah.
Alright.
So I- Yeah, all the fights are so easy if you do them
lazily.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Oopsie!
Oh!
Oh, wait!
He came back!
Stupid kid.
Stupid.
I don't know where he's shooting from, though.
Oh, there.
You can see the glint, yeah.
No, I don't.
Oh, what?
Where did he come from?
I actually don't know where that was.
Oh, shit, not that.
Oops.
What?
Where'd glint?
There's like a...
see a little bit of a sun like a a sun ray in your vision
maybe he's in the same spot as before no he moved he moved
again yeah yeah what the he came back because i got you got
hung up i got hung up he's like i'm back stupid kid oh my
god okay now okay now now he's baiting me now i'm because i
don't know if he's back or not
this this this old man this guy go to another area all right
i'll do one last look around oh my god just because i got
shot just because i got shot there you go damn good oh yeah
that's that's good as yeah baby all right i'm just gonna
make sure just
want to make sure i'm so paranoid from this fucker now I'm
like oh I got no to explore and I fucking shows up
all right which one's the river left to right just explore
which was the river left or right left then it might not
even be that bad it might not even be that one
Time to explore.
Alright, I would check the map here too and see where it
could be.
Oh, they're skidding.
Sorry.
Oh my god, I see him.
I see him.
There he is.
I actually did not see him, but...
I think I see him.
I see him.
Oh, yeah, I see him.
There I got him.
Yay!
nice okay oh see it didn't take me two weeks well well if
you wait a week and you come back um he's dead oh what he
dies of old age oh wait i save and then leave and come back
yeah yeah yeah he dies of old age the time has come for a
younger generation to rise oh no oh no more than a century
is he peeing on him no his his camo is decaying oh
so cool grandpa grandpa
what the fuck is that why you want to be a way to oh my god
goodbye is that why You wanted me to weigh up next to me and
I just come back and he's dead No, where you saved it would
have been he was fine Oh, I saved at there Yeah, if you
saved mid-fight then he would have just died Yeah, I just
come back I was like, what happened to the boss?
Yeah, there's a cutscene There's like a special cutscene for
it It's pretty funny
You know, they never explain why that happens Why did it
explode?
Yeah, I'm just like what happens?
Why did they all explode?
Oh no, I don't mean the explosion there's kind of like a
theory on the explosion but yeah why the tree opens up like
that's just kind of random because like his power of the
forest you know the power of the forest when he dies then no
one controls the forest no oh hey there's a goat yeah these
guys are good food too it's the goat oh my god sorry I did
not mean to shoot it but I guess what do you mean you pull
down your gun I just wanted to seek you see I was trying
to...
What do you mean?
Sorry, that was an accident.
It was in this fire.
I was like, pop, pop.
Oh, sorry.
It didn't mean to shoot.
Just a little oopsie there.
It's right here.
But is there anything up here?
There's a lot of, like, items and stuff around this area.
Oh, yeah.
There's a lot to explore.
Yeah.
I don't think there's...
I'm glad they didn't.
Okay, so what happens in the river?
Because I didn't.
What?
What happens in the river?
Because clearly I didn't trigger it, so.
Was that not the river?
You'll just have to play it again.
Wait, that was not the river?
There's...
It's a different river?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh my god!
Wait, you're at the...
Oh my god, this fight is so good.
Okay, you have to go, you have to go.
I have to go.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, if that's the case, then let me grab a rat real quick.
That means I need to have some food in me.
I would eat my instant ramen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is good.
Oh, the fuck.
Where did the rat go?
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Get over here.
Oh, yeah, thank you.
Oh, okay.
Whatever.
aim don't go aim don't go aim don't go aim don't go
there's the aim
yeah I got my rat oh wait you got your rat oh shit okay I
mean bats are good too yeah you could get bats yeah yeah oh
oh wait crocodile hat oh oh
Nice.
Begun!
Oh, I could just whack it.
Oh, you can just whack it.
I don't even have to...
I just whack the bat with a stick.
There you go.
They're made of paper.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, is that me?
Okay, here we go.
Is that a bean?
That's a rat?
No, no, I mean, since I'm mean, I can...
Oh.
Oh, no, no, not the rats, though.
They're two in the ground.
Here we go.
go Up I go
Oh my god up by oh my god.
It's it's this it's
It's Is that the metal gear reference?
It's the legendary ladder
I'm still
Snaker Snaker Is that it was yeah, yeah, that was that was
that the boss fight the entire ladder climb Yeah, yeah,
yeah, also there's no fall damage.
So if you fall you could like just redo it really Uh-huh
Mia now now now I For some reason, now I don't believe you.
So let me save real slick.
It's a Japanese movie where the world ends in a nuclear war.
Tensions between east and west reach the breaking point.
And before anyone can stop it, they launch the ICBMs.
Humanity is wiped out by a war that no one wanted.
Oh, no.
It depicts that destruction from the eyes of ordinary
people.
Their simple daily lives are torn apart by the terrible...
Oh, it's like the Kojima game where no one has the
achievement where everyone disarms their nuclear bomb.
Oh, that's Metal Gear.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's test this theory out.
You should roll, do a flip.
Yeah!
They don't even...
Oh my God.
One more time!
Uh...
Clown, dokey bird, clown.
One more time!
I told you it was a final boss.
She doesn't even...
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, she does.
At least I have background music.
Yeah.
What a thrill.
Come on, Doki, sing along.
What a fear in my heart.
But you are so supreme.
I give my life
for you Snake eater In my time There'll be no fight
It's the way to you I'm still In a dream Snake eater Oh my
god, how am I still climbing?
I'm still in our dreams.
Snake in the air.
Do it again, again, again.
We are walking through this door because I found out that...
again again and then we save here oh my god we're about to
get to the vultures that will eat the people and then if you
eat the vultures you're also eating the people do you want
to save yes i do okay okay have you ever seen forbidden
planet forbidden planet our last fun fact it's about this
expedition that goes to the king in an ultra fast spaceship
when they arrive of the last expedition, Dr. Morbius.
Dr. Morbius was exploring the planet along with his
daughter, Altera, and the versatile Robbie the Robot.
Robbie the Robot.
The Expedition Team is suddenly attacked by an invisible
creature called the Monster from the Id.
The special effects they use for the science stuff were
really neat.
Cool.
I wish I had a robot like Robbie that could make anything I
wanted it to.
Ah.
I'm interested in that invisible monster.
If I were invisible, I wouldn't have to bother hiding.
That's so true.
camouflage maybe so true yeah that'll be the day oh yeah
baby all right i think this is a good time to cut we got two
snake eat three technically three snake eater songs today
yeah and you got three bosses that's crazy oh that's true
yeah and then four if you count ocelot oh yeah five if you
count the ladder yeah me beating the ladder boss twice too
in the room yeah yeah six six six bosses today six bosses
today that's crazy and then like there's a huge gap till the
next boss right oh there's a bit of a gap yeah yeah because
like i i was surprised because i was like i thought they
would they would like pace the pace all three of the the
bosses for those guys but i was like it's not really a huge
gap but it's um It's a really annoying area.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I guess.
I mean, you know what?
We made a lot of progress.
Is this halfway?
People are saying like, this is halfway.
Or we're almost at halfway.
Yeah.
Oh.
I think you're really zooming.
Yeah, I think I'm just shooting everything.
Yeah, yeah.
It's great.
I'm just like, I did do a stealth.
I did do a stealthily at one.
point just regret burning the bodies after but like you know
it was technically stealth i feel like you could get it done
in next stream wait really like i feel like the first time
we you played you were very much getting used to it and just
kind of whatever but i feel like you could finish it next
stream oh okay yeah i think so too we could do it next week
actually then we could finish it right let me see yeah let's
check your schedule we will talk we'll talk after it was i
next Yeah, the week after, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Self means no witnesses, so I had to burn the bodies right
after.
Oh, it's so true.
Yeah, yeah.
They don't, like, burn.
Yeah, they technically burn so hard that they turn into
ashes.
If you think about it.
But I don't see any ashes.
Oh, the ashes also got burnt to the crisp.
I burned the ashes, so then it burns into nothing.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, that's how it goes.
Yeah, we made a lot of progress, guys.
We made a lot.
yeah ggs yeah ggs ggs i am tired oh you did technically you
did two streams technically with alan lake yeah this was
like really long yeah i did not access the lake for hours
but i was like you know what there's another boss fight and
then you wanted to you knew about the ladder you wanted us
to get to the ladder yeah sorry i've made you i forced you
to go through that and fight
You only died once.
Yeah, yeah.
Only died once, technically.
I'm going to cheat cheese, everyone.
Men and I are going to pass out now.
And bye.
Bye.
Oh, as always, everybody, I'm so tired.
I think it's a help that I'm also sick, too, I think.
So, like, my energy is a lot, like, I replenish my energy a
lot faster.
But as always, everybody, say hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around.
blood flow and you stay up for me and mint head to bed
because you deserve it but having a very fun but honestly
i've been having really fun with metal gear so far yes i'm
glad i'm slowly understanding the metal gear references and
also i i sort of i understand the ocelot thing now i i get
it like the fact that he wore the bullet like the bullet as
a necklace like i was like oh Oh, no, they're in love.
He's in, yeah, he's like, he's in deep.
Yeah, he's in deep, deep.
And it's, and he was saying, it's forbidden love, too.
He's like, I can't love an American dog.
But then secretly, he's like, oh, no.
It's forbidden.
So then after this game, you're going to play the first two,
right?
We'll talk later.
You have to see more of Ocelot.
Wait, but then he's not, he's not like a cute, like, he's
not like a cute young man.
What do you mean he's not a cute?
Yeah, he's going to be an old man.
Isn't he an old man in other games?
That's even cuter.
Yeah, old, old man love.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Okay.
Think of the old man.
Yeah.
I'm slowly understanding the Metal Gear references the
moment I saw the ladder I was like oh that's where the
ladder came from that's where the metal gear references oh
yeah the slow burn the ultra slow burn it is like the
ultimate slow burn it lasts decades that's true that's true
even after the cold war ended it's still going on it's going
on that's so true anyways we're gonna head off now hope you
guys had a fun time watching bye bye everyone bye bye bye